Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Today's episode deals with a crime committed against a child that won't be suitable for all listeners. As the midweek workday was wrapping up on Wednesday, November 11, 1987, staff were closing stores and filtering out of offices throughout Ipswich, an inland urban region on the western edge of Brisbane in Queensland, Australia. At 5.30pm, 24 year old retail assistant Cheryl Mortimer finished her shift at the Target department store located in
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目简介。今天的节目涉及针对儿童的犯罪，并非适合所有听众。1987年11月11日星期三，当周中工作日即将结束时，澳大利亚昆士兰州布里斯班西部内陆城区伊普斯威奇（Ipswich）各地的员工们正准备关门下班，陆陆续续离开办公室。下午5点30分，24岁的零售店助理谢丽尔·莫蒂默（Cheryl Mortimer）结束了她在位于以下地点的Target百货公司的值班：
the Buval Fair shopping centre. After business hours, activity around the centre had died down significantly and very few people were still around. The adjacent car park, which was usually packed with cars, was now quiet and near deserted. Cheryl collected her vehicle and drove towards the parking light exit, where her attention was drawn to an unassuming middle-aged woman with short hair and a frumpy physique. The woman was flagging Cheryl down, indicating she needed directions. Cheryl pulled over to assist. As the two women interacted, a younger looking, slim man seemingly sprang out of nowhere and rushed at Cheryl, placing a knife to her throat. The man cut his own hand with the knife accidentally, leaving his bloody fingerprints
布瓦尔费尔（Buval Fair）购物中心。营业时间过后，购物中心周围的活动已经明显减少，周围几乎看不到什么人。通常停满汽车的邻近停车场现在一片寂静，几乎荒无人烟。谢丽尔取了车，朝停车场的车灯出口开去，这时她的注意力被一个相貌平平的中年妇女吸引了，该女子留着短发，身材臃肿。那名妇女向谢丽尔招手，示意她需要指路。谢丽尔把车停在路边帮忙。正当这两个女人互动时，一个看起来较年轻、身材苗条的男子似乎凭空冒了出来，冲向谢丽尔，把一把刀架在她的喉咙上。那男子用刀不小心割伤了自己的手，留下了血淋淋的指纹
smeared on the window of Cheryl's car. The attack came to an abrupt halt when one of Cheryl's colleagues appeared and approached the scene, causing the man and woman to flee in a white-holden Kingswood station wagon. Shaken but otherwise unheard, Cheryl went straight to the police station to report the incident, providing a detailed statement of her ordeal, including a description of the perpetrator's vehicle and her best recollection of its licence plate. She believed it to have been an interstate licence plate, perhaps from New South Wales, with the registration number LLE 439. By seven o'clock that evening, Ipswich police tracked down the person linked to the registration number given by Cheryl Mortimer. They discovered the licence plates
涂抹在谢丽尔的车窗上。当谢丽尔的一位同事出现并走近现场时，袭击戛然而止，导致那名男子和女子乘坐一辆白色的霍顿金斯伍德（Holden Kingswood）旅行车逃跑。谢丽尔虽然受到惊吓，但所幸没有受伤，她直接去了警察局报案，详细陈述了她的遭遇，包括袭击者的车辆描述以及她对车牌的最好回忆。她认为这是一块州际车牌，可能来自新南威尔士州，登记号为LLE 439。当天晚上七点左右，伊普斯威奇警方追踪到了与谢丽尔·莫蒂默提供的登记号相关的人。他们发现车牌
were attached to a Toyota Corolla sedan, not a holding station wagon. Its owner resided in a country town in the neighbouring state of New South Wales and had been nowhere near Queensland that night, indicating Cheryl had misread her perpetrator's licence plate. The bloody fingerprint was taken from the window of Cheryl's car, but with no suspects to compare it to, all officers could do was store it on file in hopes it might lead them to identifying the perpetrator in the future. Despite having little to go on, Detective Constable Graham Hall of the Ipswich Criminal Investigation Branch was determined to find Cheryl Mortimer's attackers. He ran a small notice about the assault in the local Ipswich newspaper. This publicity led to two nurses
挂在一辆丰田花冠（Toyota Corolla）轿车上，而不是霍顿旅行车上。车主居住在邻近的新南威尔士州的一个乡村小镇，那天晚上根本不在昆士兰州附近，这表明谢丽尔看错了袭击者的车牌。血腥指纹是从谢丽尔的车窗上提取的，但由于没有嫌疑人可供比对，警察们所能做的就是将其存档，希望将来能凭此查明袭击者的身份。尽管线索寥寥，但伊普斯威奇刑事调查分局的警长格雷厄姆·霍尔（Graham Hall）决心找到谢丽尔·莫蒂默的袭击者。他在当地的伊普斯威奇报纸上登了一则关于这起袭击的小广告。这一宣传引来了两名护士
from Ipswich General Hospital coming forward, both revealing they too had frightening encounters with a man in a white Kingswood Holden station wagon. These encounters occurred on Tuesday, November 10, the night before Cheryl Mortimer's attack. Both confrontations occurred late at night in the hospital car park when the women were leaving work. In one instance, the man banged on the window of one of the nurses' cars, giving her such a fright that she locked her doors and quickly drove away. The other nurse, Nicole Close, had been coaxed out of her vehicle by the man who was holding a map and requesting directions. He stood far too close to Nicole for comfort, but her nervousness became stomach-turning fear when she noticed Hessian bags and ropes in the
来自伊普斯威奇综合医院（Ipswich General Hospital）的护士主动提供线索，两人都透露她们也曾与一名驾驶白色金斯伍德·霍顿旅行车的男子有过可怕的遭遇。这些遭遇发生在11月10日星期二，即谢丽尔·莫蒂默遇袭的前一晚。这两起对抗都发生在深夜的医院停车场，当时这些女性正下班离开。其中一次，该男子敲击其中一名护士的车窗，吓得她锁上车门，迅速开车逃跑。另一名护士尼科尔·克洛斯（Nicole Close）被该男子诱出了车外，当时他拿着地图请求指路。他离尼科尔太近了，让她感到很不舒服，但当她注意到车后座上有麻袋和绳索时，她的紧张变成了翻江倒海的恐惧。
back seat of his car. She was inadvertently saved by another hospital employee who happened to pass by, startling the man and giving Nicole the opportunity to jump back into her own vehicle and drive away. Nicole Close told police she thought the license plate of the man's white station wagon was LLF-429. This was near identical to the license plate number given by Cheryl Mortimer, except for a minor difference in a letter and digit. There was little doubt that all three women were confronted by the same man using the same vehicle, and in Cheryl's case, he was assisted by an older woman. Yet, an interstate search on the license plate registration offered by Nicole Close also came up blank. A police staffer spent their entire
她无意中被另一位恰巧路过的医院员工所救，这吓坏了那名男子，并给了尼科尔跳回自己车里开车逃跑的机会。尼科尔·克洛斯告诉警察，她认为那名男子的白色旅行车的车牌是LLF-429。这与谢丽尔·莫蒂默给出的车牌号几乎完全相同，只有一个字母和数字的微小差异。毫无疑问，这三名女性都遇到了驾驶同一辆车的同一个男人，而在谢丽尔的案子中，他得到了一个年长女子的协助。然而，对尼科尔·克洛斯提供的车牌登记进行的州际搜索也一无所获。一名警务人员花了一整天的时间
shift sifting through a vehicle database, running combinations of letters and numbers of the perpetrator's registration provided by their victims, hoping to stumble across one linked to a Holden Kingswood station wagon. This extensive search proved fruitless, and the couple accosting women throughout Ipswich remained unidentified. Although the perpetrators were still on the loose, no further incidents were reported to Ipswich police over the following weeks, leading investigators to hope the couple's terrifying crime spree had come to an end. Friday, November 27, 1987.
值班时仔细筛选车辆数据库，组合受害者提供的袭击者注册号的字母和数字，希望能偶然发现与霍顿·金斯伍德旅行车相关的车牌。这次广泛的搜查毫无结果，在整个伊普斯威奇骚扰女性的那对夫妇仍然身份不明。尽管袭击者仍然在逃，但在接下来的几周里，伊普斯威奇警方没有接到进一步的事件报告，这让调查人员希望这对夫妇可怕的犯罪狂潮已经结束。1987年11月27日星期五。
A warm spring day in the coastal retreat of Nusa, typical weather for Queensland's Sunshine Coast, 180 kilometres north of Ipswich. Before it was renamed Nusa Heads in 1988 and became a cosmopolitan playground for cached-up holidaymakers, Nusa was a quiet, safe town, populated by sun-seeking retirees and young families. They were lured by its perfect weather and pristine beaches, looking to escape the big city for a more laid-back, seaside lifestyle. Thirty-one-year-old bartender Elizabeth Young and her friend Bill Wallace decided to make the most of the barmy weather by spending the afternoon swimming at Castaway's Beach, a stretch of ocean around seven kilometres south of the Nusa township. After eating lunch, Elizabeth and Bill
努萨（Noosa）海滨度假胜地的一个温暖的春日，这是昆士兰州阳光海岸的典型天气，位于伊普斯威奇以北180公里处。在1988年更名为努萨角（Noosa Heads）并成为身家丰厚的度假者的国际化游乐场之前，努萨是一个安静、安全的小镇，居住着寻阳光的退休人员和年轻家庭。他们被这里完美的天气和原始的海滩所吸引，希望逃离大城市，寻找一种更悠闲的海滨生活方式。31岁的调酒师伊丽莎白·杨（Elizabeth Young）和她的朋友比尔·华莱士（Bill Wallace）决定充分利用这温和的天气，下午去卡斯塔韦斯海滩（Castaway's Beach）游泳，这是一段距离努萨镇南部约七公里的海岸。吃完午餐后，伊丽莎白和比尔
were cooling off in the surf, when suddenly the black Labrador dog they had brought along started growling at someone who was walking along the shoreline. Elizabeth looked up to see an unshaven man who appeared to be aged in his 30s. His sun-bleached hair was typical of the area, but his scruffy, King G brand industrial workshorts and shirt was out of place attire for the beach. Elizabeth recalled, quote, he looked like a farmer looking for his cows. There was something very odd about the way he was dressed, and he wasn't looking at the water. The man looked vaguely familiar to Elizabeth. She thought she had seen him the previous day, too, looking similarly dishevelled, perhaps even drunk. Elizabeth waved and called out a greeting, but the man did not
正在海浪中凉爽一下，突然他们带来的那只黑色拉布拉多犬开始对一个沿着海岸线散步的人咆哮。伊丽莎白抬头看到一个没刮胡子的男人，看起来30多岁。他被阳光晒得褪色的头发是当地的典型特征，但他那件衣衫褴褛的King G品牌工业工作短裤和衬衫与海滩格格不入。伊丽莎白回忆说：“他看起来像个在找牛的农夫。”他的穿着方式有些非常奇怪，而且他根本没有看水。这个男人对伊丽莎白来说有点面熟。她觉得她前一天也见过他，同样衣衫褴褛，甚至可能喝醉了。伊丽莎白挥手打招呼，但那个人没有
respond. Instead, he gave her an unwavering cold stare, which along with the aggressive reaction of her usually placid dog, made the hairs on the back of Elizabeth's neck prickle with alarm. The unknown man resumed walking with purpose back and forth among the dunes as if he was searching for something. Bill suggested to Elizabeth that they head to the car park to check on his vehicle, as it had been broken into several times whilst parked at Castaway's beach, and he suspected the stranger might be responsible. When the pair reached the car park, Bill's land cruiser was still locked, and nothing had been taken. But Bill didn't like the look of the only other vehicle in the small car park, a white, dust-covered, holding Kingswood station wagon
回应。相反，他给了她一个坚定而冰冷的凝视，再加上她那只平时温顺的狗的攻击性反应，让伊丽莎白脖子后面的汗毛惊恐地竖了起来。那个陌生人在沙丘间坚定地来回走动，仿佛在寻找什么。比尔建议伊丽莎白去停车场检查一下他的车，因为他的车停在卡斯塔韦斯海滩时曾多次被盗，他怀疑这个陌生人可能是罪魁祸首。当两人到达停车场时，比尔的陆地巡洋舰（Land Cruiser）仍然锁着，什么也没丢。但比尔不喜欢小停车场里唯一的一辆车，那是一辆白色的、落满灰尘的霍顿·金斯伍德旅行车
with a black and white license plate that indicated it was registered interstate. Bill and Elizabeth eventually returned to the beach, moving to a spot where they could keep an eye on activity around the car park. Just before 3pm, Elizabeth and Bill caught sight of the strange man from earlier getting into the white station wagon. Sensing something wasn't right, Elizabeth and Bill decided to follow the vehicle in their land cruiser, trailing its 7km northward to the Noosa Junction shopping precinct. Located a 25-minute walk from Noosa's main beach and national park, the junction was a bustling hub of supermarkets, retail stores, and cafes. Elizabeth and Bill witnessed the station wagon driving towards Pinaroo Park,
车上挂着黑白相间的车牌，表明它是外州注册的。比尔和伊丽莎白最终回到了海滩，移动到一个可以留意停车场周围活动的地方。下午3点前不久，伊丽莎白和比尔看到早些时候那个奇怪的男人上了那辆白色旅行车。意识到情况不对劲，伊丽莎白和比尔决定驾驶他们的陆地巡洋舰跟随这辆车，向北追踪7公里来到努萨章克申（Noosa Junction）购物区。该交汇处距离努萨的主海滩和国家公园有25分钟的步行路程，是一个集超市、零售店和咖啡馆于一体的繁华中心。伊丽莎白和比尔目睹这辆旅行车驶向皮纳鲁公园（Pinaroo Park），
a large section of woodland located at the rear of the Noosa Junction shopping centre. The park backed onto Noosa's suburbs, making its narrow, tree-lined pathways a useful thoroughfare for those walking to and from the junction. But its hidden away aspect also made it a popular place for late-night parties and hangouts. It was at this time that Elizabeth and Bill lost sight of the station wagon in traffic. The entire situation unnerved Elizabeth, but she and Bill agreed that they couldn't go to the police to report someone simply because they seemed strange. They put the occurrence to the back of their minds and continued on with their day. That same afternoon, at around 3.30pm, the end of day bell rang out across Queensland
这是一片位于努萨章克申购物中心后方的巨大林地。该公园背靠努萨的郊区，其狭窄、树木林立的小路是那些往返于该交汇处的人们的便利通道。但其隐蔽的一面也使其成为深夜派对和聚会的热门场所。正是在这个时候，伊丽莎白和比尔在交通中失去了那辆旅行车的踪迹。整件事情让伊丽莎白感到不安，但她和比尔一致认为，他们不能仅仅因为某人看起来奇怪就去警察局报警。他们把这件事抛在脑后，继续他们的日常生活。当天下午，大约3点30分，放学铃声在昆士兰州各地响起。
schoolyards. Year 7 student, 12-year-old Sean Kingey rushed out of her classroom at Sunshine Beach School and immediately jumped on her prized possession, her 10-speed yellow Repco racing bike. She rode over to meet her mother, Linda, at the Noosa Fair Shopping Centre in Noosa Junction. Linda had agreed to help her daughter find the perfect material to make into a skirt for a birthday party Sean was attending over the weekend. Sean was excited about Sunday's party. She was popular among her classmates and loved to socialise and dance. At school, she enjoyed a jazz ballet and playing on the netball team, her 167cm slim frame giving her a significant height advantage over the other girls her age. Sean inherited long, straight,
学校操场上。7年级学生、12岁的肖恩·金基（Sean Kingi）冲出阳光海滩学校（Sunshine Beach School）的教室，立刻跳上了她最珍贵的财产——她那辆10速黄色雷普科（Repco）赛车。她骑车去努萨章克申的努萨集市购物中心（Noosa Fair Shopping Centre）与母亲琳达（Linda）会合。琳达同意帮女儿挑选完美的布料，为肖恩周末要参加的生日派对做一条短裙。肖恩对周日的派对感到兴奋。她在同学中很受欢迎，喜欢社交和跳舞。在学校里，她喜欢爵士芭蕾舞和打无板篮球，她167厘米的纤细身材使她在同龄的其他女孩中具有显着的身高优势。肖恩继承了长而直的头发，
golden blonde hair from her mother's side that had the olive skin and enormous dark eyes of her maury father. Teachers found her quiet and well behaved and she charmed everyone she met with her shy nature and good manners. At around 4.45pm, the mother and daughter successfully completed their mission to find material for Sean's skirt. Before embarking on the 1km walk back to their house in Noosa's suburbs, Linda decided to stop in to the bakery to buy a loaf of bread for the weekend. Sean told her mother that she would get a head start on her bike as she was eager to change out of her school uniform, a blue and white striped summer dress. Linda Kingey didn't hesitate in agreeing to let her daughter make the short bike ride home.
她母亲那边的金黄色头发，拥有她毛利父亲的橄榄色皮肤和巨大的黑眼睛。老师们觉得她安静、守规矩，她害羞的本性和良好的礼貌迷住了她遇到的每一个人。下午4点45分左右，母女俩成功完成了为肖恩的裙子寻找布料的任务。在踏上返回努萨郊区家中的1公里步行路程之前，琳达决定顺便去面包店买一条周末吃的面包。肖恩告诉母亲她要骑自行率先出发，因为她急于换下她的校服——一件蓝白相间的夏季条纹连衣裙。琳达·金基毫不犹豫地同意让女儿骑短途自行车回家。
Noosa in the 80s was like a country town on the beach, safe and secure, where no one was a stranger. Parents didn't think twice about letting their children walk or ride their bikes till and from school or to visit friends and play in the park until it was time to come home for dinner. After she purchased the bread, Linda would take a shortcut home along the sandy walking path. Meanwhile, Sean would ride along the bike track through nearby Piniru Park. The bike track weaved from behind the brightly lit busy shopping centre through picturesque, quiet parklands of the reserve. It was a kilometre long ride Sean had taken a hundred times before. Despite the extra distance, with the head start, Sean would easily beat her mother home.
8年代的努萨就像海滩上的乡村小镇，安全稳妥，没有人是陌生人。父母们不会三思而后行，就让孩子们步行或骑自行车上下学，或者去拜访朋友并在公园里玩耍，直到回家吃晚饭的时间。买完面包后，琳达会沿着沙质步行小路走捷径回家。与此同时，肖恩将骑自行车穿过附近的皮鲁公园（Piniru Park）的车道。这条自行车道从灯火通明、繁忙的购物中心后面蜿蜒穿过保护区风景如画、宁静的公园。这是一段肖恩以前骑过一百次的1公里长的骑行。尽管距离较长，但有了领先优势，肖恩很容易就能比母亲先到家。
The 12-year-old slung her olive green school bag over her shoulders, climbed onto her bike and set off. Linda selected a loaf from the hot bread display, her transaction which only took a couple of minutes. She then started the walk to the Kingi family homestead via the sandy track. When Linda arrived home a short time later, Sean and her bike were nowhere to be seen. Linda didn't think much of it, assuming her daughter had run into some friends on the way home and stopped to chat about school or the forthcoming party. However, when dusk approached and Sean still hadn't returned home, Linda became increasingly concerned. Her daughter was not prone to disobedience or thoughtlessness and it was very out of character for her to stay out
这名12岁的女孩把她那橄榄绿的书包背在肩上，爬上自行车出发了。琳达从热面包柜台挑选了一条面包，交易只花了区区几分钟。然后她开始沿着沙地小路步行前往金基家族的宅基地。不久后，当琳达回到家时，肖恩和她的自行车不见踪影。琳达并没有多想，以为女儿在回家的路上遇到了几个朋友，停下来聊了聊学校的事或即将到来的派对。然而，随着暮色降临，肖恩依然没有回家，琳达越来越担心。她的女儿一向不听话或考虑不周，在明知被允许的时间之外待这么晚，这很不符合她的性格。琳达拿起电话，开始给肖恩的所有朋友打电话，试图找到她。
so much later than she knew she was allowed to. Linda picked up the phone and began making calls to all of Sean's friends, trying to locate her. But each response confirmed that none of them had seen Sean since they left school for the day. Sean's father, Barry Kingi, arrived home a little after 8pm and was immediately alerted to the fact that Linda hadn't seen their daughter since the pair had parted ways at Noosa Junction around 4.45pm. The couple immediately set off to Pinaroo Park to retrace the route Sean would have taken, hoping to find her along the way. When the concerned parents arrived at the bike track, it only took them a few minutes to find Sean's yellow bike discarded on the side of the path, but there was no sign of their daughter.
但每个回应都证实，自从他们白天放学后，他们谁也没有见过肖恩。肖恩的父亲巴里·金基（Barry Kingi）在晚上8点刚过回到家，并立即得知琳达自下午4点45分左右两人在努萨章克申分道扬镳后就再也没有见过他们的女儿。这对夫妇立即动身前往皮纳鲁公园，沿着肖恩可能走过的路线原路返回，希望能在路上找到她。当这对焦虑的父母到达自行车道时，他们只花了几分钟就在小路边找到了肖恩被扔掉的黄色自行车，但没有女儿的踪影。
Knowing there was no way Sean would have willingly abandoned her beloved bike, Linda and Barry placed the bicycle into the trailer of Barry's ute and headed straight to the police station. The couple walked into the Noosa police station at 8.40pm and presented their daughter's photograph to Detective Sergeant Bob Ackinson. Noosa was a town of less than 15,000 residents and Sergeant Ackinson knew 12-year-old Sean Kingi by sight as she played in the same netball league as his own daughter. The Kingi's assured Ackinson that would be completely out of character for Sean to run away or not come home by nightfall. Ackinson accompanied the Kingi's back to Pinaroo Park to check whether Sean had perhaps
明知肖恩绝不可能自愿抛弃她心爱的自行车，琳达和巴里把自行车装进巴里的皮卡车拖车里，径直开往警察局。这对夫妇于晚上8点40分走进努萨警察局，将女儿的照片交给警长鲍勃·阿金森（Bob Ackinson）。努萨是一个居民不到1.5万人的小镇，阿金森警长一眼就认出了12岁的肖恩·金基，因为她和他自己的女儿在同一个无板篮球联赛中打球。金基夫妇向阿金森保证，肖恩离家出走或天黑前不回家是极其反常的。阿金森陪同金基夫妇返回皮纳鲁公园，检查肖恩是否可能
injured herself or fallen unconscious nearby, but Sean wasn't there and neither were her belongings. Detective Sergeant Ackinson was highly concerned, but he knew theirs was a safe and close knit community, so he tried to remain positive. Quote, I would have thought that 5.30 in the afternoon in Noosa in summer would have been one of the safest places in Australia for a kitty to be. Upon returning to the station, Ackinson rang the night desk of the local newspaper Sunshine Coast to Daily. It was past the deadline for print submissions, but the newspaper made an exception and agreed to run the photograph of Sean along with the details of her disappearance for the Saturday morning edition of the paper. Sean Kingi was officially declared a missing person.
自己受伤了或在附近昏迷不醒，但肖恩不在那里，她的随身物品也不在。警长鲍勃·阿金森非常担心，但他知道这是一个安全且紧密的社区，所以他试图保持积极态度。“我想，夏天努萨下午5点半应该是全澳大利亚对一个小女孩来说最安全的地方之一。”回到警察局后，阿金森拨打了当地报纸《阳光海岸日报》（Sunshine Coast Daily）的夜间值班台。当时已经过了印刷截稿时间，但该报破例同意在周六早晨的报纸版面上刊登肖恩的照片以及她失踪的详情。肖恩·金基被正式宣布为失踪人口。
Barry and Linda Kingi endured a sleepless night without their daughter. They waited anxiously for daybreak when they could resume their inquiries around town, aided by the news release that would appear in the morning's paper. Although no information about Sean's whereabouts came in overnight, by the time the sun came up, every available police officer in the Noosa district was assigned to be on the lookout for Sean Kingi. As news of Sean Kingi's disappearance spread throughout the local community, leads started trickling in. Some witnesses reported seeing Sean in Pineroo Park on the day of her disappearance, but had not noted her as being in danger. A couple of people also reported having seen cars in a parking bay at the edge of the
巴里和琳达·金基度过了一个没有女儿的无眠之夜。他们焦急地等待天亮，以便在早报新闻发布的协助下恢复在镇上的调查。尽管夜间没有收到任何关于肖恩下落的消息，但当地面阳光升起时，努萨地区所有可用的警察都被指派去寻找肖恩·金基。随着肖恩·金基失踪的消息在当地社区传开，线索开始源源不断地涌来。一些目击者报告说，在肖恩失踪当天在皮纳鲁公园看到了她，但并没有注意到她处于危险之中。还有几个人报告说，在肖恩失踪的时候，看到有车停在保护区边缘的一个停车位里，
reserve around the time Sean went missing, one of which was described as a white, dust-covered station wagon. Members of the community reported every single detail they thought may help, no matter how minor. Every flasher, loiterer, pickpocket, drug dealer, and suspicious-looking stranger were hauled into the police station for questioning. However, nothing discussed led to Sean's whereabouts. The people of Noosa and the surrounding Sunshine Coast District banded together like they never had before, united in the quest to find young Sean Kingi as fears for her safety grew. The community gave an outpouring of support to the girl's concerned parents, while Detective Sergeant Atkinson took the Kingi family under his wing,
其中一辆被描述为一辆白色的、落满灰尘的旅行车。社区成员报告了他们认为可能有所帮助的每一个细节，无论多么微不足道。每一个闪光者、游荡者、扒手、毒贩和形迹可疑的陌生人都被拉到警察局接受讯问。然而，讨论的内容没有带来肖恩的下落。努萨和周边阳光海岸地区的居民像以前从未有过的那样团结起来，齐心协力寻找年轻的肖恩·金基，因为人们对她的安全的担忧日益加剧。社区对这个女孩担忧的父母给予了倾力的支持，而阿金森警长则将金基家族护在羽翼之下，
personally ensuring they were kept in the loop every step of the investigation. On Sunday, November 29, Sean's friends celebrated the birthday of a classmate at Noosa National Park. Sean had been looking forward to the party all week, the fabric she had carefully selected for her party skirt sitting untouched at home. Sean had been missing for two days, and hope remained high that the 12-year-old would suddenly reappear and attend the party. But that hope was soon shattered when Sean was a no-show. With no sign of Sean emerging, the Noosa Police Department put in a call to the Brisbane Homicide Squad and requested for as many detectives as they could spare to make the 140-kilometer trip up the coast. Although there was no evidence to suggest Sean
亲自确保他们在调查的每一步都了解最新进展。11月29日星期日，肖恩的朋友们在努萨国家公园庆祝了一位同学的生日。肖恩整个星期都对这个派对充满期待，她精心挑选的派对短裙面料还静静地放在家里。肖恩已经失踪两天了，人们依然抱有希望，希望这个12岁的女孩会突然出现并参加派对。但当肖恩没有出现时，这种希望很快破灭了。由于没有肖恩的踪迹，努萨警察局致电布里斯班凶杀组，请求尽可能多地抽调侦探，进行这趟沿海岸向上140公里的行程。尽管没有证据表明肖恩
had been killed, a dozen homicide detectives converged on the Noosa township to offer their assistance in the search. A command center was set up in Noosa's Criminal Investigation Branch, and it was manned around the clock. In an attempt to jog memories, a mannequin dressed in Sean's blue and white striped school dress was put on display in Pinaroo Park, near the location she was last seen. By Sunday evening, Sean's disappearance was headlining every local news bulletin, resulting in a flood of leads to Noosa Police. Many of these reports led nowhere. They were observations or incidents unrelated to Sean's disappearance, the product of overactive imaginations, or created purely for attention. Unsubstantiated sightings were abundant, placing Sean near
被杀害，一打凶杀案侦探聚集到努萨镇，为搜寻工作提供协助。努萨刑事调查分局设立了一个指挥中心，并由专人昼夜值班。为了唤起人们的记忆，一个穿着肖恩蓝白相间校服裙的模特被摆放在皮纳鲁公园里，靠近她最后一次被看到的地方。到周日晚上，肖恩的失踪成了各大地方新闻播报的头条，导致大量线索涌入努萨警方。这些报告中的许多都无果而终。它们是与肖恩失踪无关的观察或事件，是过度活跃的想象力的产物，或者是纯粹为了引起注意而制造的。未经证实的目击事件层出不穷，将肖恩置于
the local bowls club, tennis courts, surf club, and even hitchhiking northbound. Investigations were stifled from clairvoyance who insisted on having their visions taken seriously, and mentally unwell people who confessed to the crime, but could provide no further information than what was in the papers. A total of 700 leads were investigated, most taking the investigation nowhere. However, there was one detail that kept coming up in various reports. Witness sightings of a white station wagon without a state license plates in the vicinity of Pinaroo Park at the time Sean vanished. The description of this station wagon differed in each statement. Some witnesses claimed the vehicle had curtains, yet others were certain
当地的滚球俱乐部、网球场、冲浪俱乐部，甚至是在向北搭便车。调查受到了一些声称必须认真对待其“特异功能”的预言家的阻挠，还有精神状况不佳的人自首供认犯罪，却提供不出比报纸上更多的信息。总共调查了700条线索，其中大部分让调查陷入死胡同。然而，有一个细节在各种报告中不断出现。目击者在肖恩失踪时看到一辆没有州车牌的白色旅行车在皮纳鲁公园附近出现。每份陈述中对这辆旅行车的描述各不相同。一些目击者称这辆车有窗帘，而另一些人则确信
they could see inside, and it may or may not have had mag wheels or roof racks. But despite these conflicting specifics, the vehicle was consistently described as a dusty, white station wagon, likely a Holden Kingswood model that was several years old. Witnesses who had caught a glimpse of the vehicle's occupants provided a description of a man with a surfy-like appearance who was in the company of a plump woman. None had seen a little girl. Police urged everyone in the Sunshine Coast District who had a vehicle that so much as vaguely matched the witness descriptions of the white station wagon to come forward,
他们可以看到里面，它可能装有也可能没有铝合金轮毂或车顶行李架。尽管这些细节相互冲突，但这辆车始终被描述为一辆落满灰尘的白色旅行车，很可能是车龄几年的霍顿·金斯伍德车型。瞥见车上乘客的目击者描述说，一个具有冲浪运动员外貌的男子陪伴着一个丰满的女子。没有人看到一个小女孩。警方敦促阳光海岸地区所有拥有甚至勉强符合目击者对白色旅行车描述的车辆的车主站出来，
so their car could be eliminated from the investigation. Every white station wagon that ventured onto Queensland roads was pulled over, many several times a day. The drivers aggressively questioned about their whereabouts the previous Friday evening. To save time, police issued drivers who were cleared of any suspicion with a card that they could flash should they be pulled over again, as proof that they had been given the all clear. The search for the vehicle of interest in the Sharn Kingi missing person investigation was no small feat. Holden Kingswood station wagons were an exceedingly common type of car, with 17,000 of them registered in Queensland alone, 10,000 of which were white.
以便将他们的汽车排除在调查之外。每一辆冒险开上昆士兰州道路的白色旅行车都被拦下，许多车一天被拦下好几次。司机们被咄咄逼人地盘问他们上周五晚上的行踪。为了节省时间，警方给洗清嫌疑的司机发了一张卡片，如果他们再次被拦下，可以出示这张卡片，作为他们已被证明完全清白的证明。在肖恩·金基失踪案中寻找相关车辆绝非易事。霍顿·金斯伍德旅行车是一种极其常见的车型，仅在昆士兰州就注册了1.7万辆，其中1万辆是白色的。
Having worked the night before and subsequently slept for most of the following day, 31-year-old bartender Elizabeth Young had missed the escalating drama regarding the disappearance of Sharn Kingi. When she was finally made aware of the news, Elizabeth couldn't believe what she was hearing. Elizabeth knew Linda Kingi as the two had worked together at the Mango Tree Cafe a few years earlier. Sharn and her younger brother used to visit the cafe after school, enjoying milkshakes while they waited for their mother to finish her shift. When police appealed for information regarding a dusty white station wagon, Elizabeth's mind immediately returned to Castaway's beach on the afternoon of Friday, November 27, the day Sharn vanished.
31岁的调酒师伊丽莎白·杨（Elizabeth Young）由于前一晚工作，随后大半天都在睡觉，错过了关于肖恩·金基失踪案不断升级的戏剧性事件。当她终于得知这个消息时，伊丽莎白简直不敢相信自己的耳朵。伊丽莎白认识琳达·金基，因为两人几年前曾在芒果树咖啡馆（Mango Tree Cafe）一起工作过。肖恩和她的弟弟过去常常放学后去咖啡馆，一边喝着奶昔，一边等他们母亲下班。当警方呼吁提供有关一辆落满灰尘的白色旅行车的线索时，伊丽莎白的脑海里立刻回到了11月27日星期五下午，即肖恩失踪的那天，在卡斯塔韦斯海滩的场景。
Elizabeth and her companion Bill Wallace witnessed a dishevelled man behaving suspiciously along the shoreline before driving off from the beach car park in a dusty white station wagon at around 3pm. Elizabeth and Bill tailed the vehicle to Noosa Junction, where they lost sight of it driving towards Pinaroo Park. After hearing about Sharn Kingi's disappearance, Elizabeth reported this information to police and investigators subsequently reached out to Bill Wallace for further information. Bill's description of both the man and the station wagon matched perfectly with the information police had already obtained from Elizabeth and other witnesses,
伊丽莎白和她的同伴比尔·华莱士目睹了一个衣衫褴褛的男子在海岸线附近表现可疑，随后于下午3点左右驾驶一辆落满灰尘的白色旅行车离开海滩停车场。伊丽莎白和比尔一路尾随这辆车来到努萨章克申，在那里他们失去了它的踪迹，它正朝皮纳鲁公园方向驶去。在听到肖恩·金基失踪的消息后，伊丽莎白向警方报告了这一信息，调查人员随后联系了比尔·华莱士以获取更多信息。比尔对那个男人和旅行车的描述与警方已经从伊丽莎白和其他目击者那里获得的信息完全吻合，
but he also had one additional detail that nobody else had reported. Whilst in the Castaway's beach parking lot, Bill had scrawled the station wagon's license plate number on a scrap of note paper, securing it in a clip that was attached to his dashboard. The note read LLE 429. Police ran this license plate number through Queensland's vehicle database, but it didn't return a match, nor did it match any registrations in the neighbouring state of New South Wales. When they plugged the number into the database of the state of Victoria, located over 1500 kilometres south of Noosa, it finally returned a hit. A white 1973 Holden Kingswood station wagon with the license plate number of LLE 429
但他还有一个别人都没有报告的额外细节。在卡斯塔韦斯海滩停车场时，比尔在一张便条纸上草草写下了旅行车的车牌号，并把它夹在他仪表盘上的夹子里。便条上写着LLE 429。警方通过昆士兰州的车辆数据库查询了这个车牌号，但没有找到匹配的结果，与邻近的新南威尔士州的任何登记信息也不匹配。当他们将这个号码输入位于努萨以南1500多公里的维多利亚州数据库时，终于有了结果。一辆白色的1973年霍顿·金斯伍德旅行车，车牌号为LLE 429
was registered to a Victorian woman, 44-year-old Valmene Fay Beck. The name meant nothing to Noosa police investigating the disappearance of Sharn Kingi, so they contacted Victoria police and asked the regional detectives there to check out Valmene Beck's address and determine why her vehicle was recently spotted in their sleepy coastal township, two states away. Victoria police detectives headed to the suburb of Meruilbark, around 35 kilometres east of Melbourne, to pay a visit to the address where Valmene Beck's station wagon was registered. Valmene Beck was not at the house, it was occupied by an elderly man who informed detectives that Valmene was the wife of his adopted son, Barry
登记在一名维多利亚州女子名下，她就是44岁的瓦尔梅尼·费·贝克（Valmene Fay Beck）。这个名字对正在调查肖恩·金基失踪案的努萨警方来说毫无意义，于是他们联系了维多利亚州警方，请那里的地区侦探去查明瓦尔梅尼·贝克的地址，并确定她的车为什么最近会被发现在他们位于两个州之外的这个沉睡的海滨小镇。维多利亚州警方侦探前往墨尔本以东约35公里的默里尔巴克（Meruilbark）郊区，拜访了登记瓦尔梅尼·贝克旅行车的地址。瓦尔梅尼·贝克不在家，房子里住着一位老人，他告诉侦探瓦尔梅尼是他养子的妻子，名叫巴里
John Watts. Beck and Watts had recently visited Melbourne from Western Australia, making the 3400 kilometre trip to the opposite side of the country in a small sedan. Whilst in Melbourne, Valmene Beck traded their sedan for a white 1973 Holden Kingswood station wagon, using her name along with her father-in-law's address on the registration documents. Not long after, Valmene Beck and Barry Watts departed for a trip up north in the station wagon, their current whereabouts unknown. Police ran a background check for both Valmene Beck and Barry Watts, discovering the couple were convicted criminals. Barry Watts had served prison time for various
约翰·沃茨（Barry John Watts）。贝克和沃茨最近从西澳大利亚州驾车来到墨尔本，开着一辆小型轿车完成了横穿整个国家的3400公里行程。在墨尔本期间，瓦尔梅尼·贝克用他们的轿车换了一辆白色的1973年霍顿·金斯伍德旅行车，在登记文件上使用了她的名字以及她公公的地址。不久之后，瓦尔梅尼·贝克和巴里·沃茨驾车踏上了向北的旅程，目前下落不明。警方对瓦尔梅尼·贝克和巴里·沃茨进行了背景调查，发现这对夫妇是有犯罪前科的人。巴里·沃茨曾因各种罪行服刑，
offences, including armed robbery and burglary. He was associated with another known criminal by the name of Valmene Forte, which investigators deduced was the previous name of Valmene Beck. She had convictions for theft, false pretenses, indecent behaviour, obscene language, forgery, and vagrancy. The criminal couple were listed as persons of interest in the Sean Kingey investigation, although a connection to the 12-year-old's disappearance wasn't immediately clear. Newster investigators arranged to have photographs of Beck and Watts sent to them by Express Mail to initiate a search for the pair. Wednesday, December 2 marked the fifth day of Sean Kingey's disappearance.
包括武装抢劫和入室盗窃。他与另一个名叫瓦尔梅尼·福尔特（Valmene Forte）的知名罪犯有过交往，调查人员推测这就是瓦尔梅尼·贝克曾用过的名字。她曾因盗窃、虚假幌子、猥亵行为、淫秽语言、伪造和流浪罪而被定罪。这对犯罪夫妇被列为肖恩·金基案的嫌疑人，尽管他们与这名12女孩失踪案的联系尚不十分明朗。新斯特（Newster）调查人员安排通过特快专递将贝克和沃茨的照片发给他们，以便对两人展开搜寻。12月2日星期三，标志着肖恩·金基失踪的第五天。
That evening, 18-year-old Neil Clark was walking home from his fruit-picking job through Timbierre Mountain State Forest, located 17 kilometres south of Newster. As he trekked along the edge of the overgrown forest of eucalyptus trees and rainforest ferns, Neil was struck by a foul stench. He decided that if the odor was still there the next morning, he would have a look around to investigate its source. At 8.50am the following morning of Thursday, December 3, Neil Clark drove his car to the area of forest where he had picked up the offensive odor the previous day. The smell was still lingering in the crisp mountain air, so Neil followed the scent, stepping off the track and venturing a short way into the forest towards Castaway's creek.
那天晚上，18岁的尼尔·克拉克（Neil Clark）结束了采摘水果的工作，正走在回家路上，穿过位于新斯特以南17公里的廷比雷山国家森林（Timbierre Mountain State Forest）。当他沿着长满桉树和雨林蕨类植物的杂草丛生的森林边缘跋涉时，尼尔闻到了一股恶臭。他决定如果第二天早上气味还在，他就在周围看一看，调查一下气味来源。第二天12月3日星期四上午8点50分，尼尔·克拉克开车来到他前一天闻到恶臭的那片森林。清凉的山间空气中依然弥漫着这股气味，于是尼尔顺着气味追踪，离开小路，向卡斯塔韦斯小溪方向的森林里走了一小段路。
Emerging from the shrubbery, Neil's attention was drawn to the bushes by the shallow creek, where he caught sight of the body of a young girl, her blue and white striped dress in disarray. Horrified, Neil stumbled back to his car, drove straight home, and called the police. Detective Sergeant Bob Atkinson was in the Noosa-based command centre, overseeing the Shang Kingi disappearance when the call from Neil Clark was placed through to him a little after 9am. Upon hearing what the young man on the other end of the phone had to say, Atkinson and Brisbane Homicide Squad Detective Senior Sergeant Bob Dallow drove straight to Timbierra Mountain State Forest. Following the directions given by Neil Clark,
从灌木丛中钻出来，尼尔的注意力被浅溪旁的灌木丛吸引了，他在那里看到了一个年轻女孩的尸体，她蓝白相间的连衣裙凌乱不堪。惊恐万状的尼尔跌跌撞撞地跑回车里，直接开车回家并报了警。警长鲍勃·阿金森当时正在努萨的指挥中心，监督肖恩·金基失踪案的搜寻工作，这时尼尔·克拉克的电话在上午9点刚过转接给他。听到电话那头年轻人的话后，阿金森和布里斯班凶杀组高级侦探鲍勃·达洛（Bob Dallow）直接驱车前往廷比拉山国家森林（Timbierra Mountain State Forest）。按照尼尔·克拉克给出的方向，
they entered the woodland, veered off the path, and headed in the direction of Castaway's creek. There, resting near the creek bank amongst the lush ferns and shady trees, was the body of 12-year-old Shang Kingi. When Shang Kingi's body was found, the 12-year-old was still dressed in her Sunshine Beach school dress, pink socks, and white sneakers. Her cut-up underwear was found nearby, and her green school backpack was located in a bush 10 metres away. A small clearing near the creek appeared recently disturbed. Her section of the grass was crushed flat in a square shape, indicating something had recently happened there.
他们走进树林，偏离小路，朝着卡斯塔韦斯小溪的方向走去。在那里，躺在溪边茂密的蕨类植物和浓荫大树之间的，是12岁肖恩·金基的尸体。当肖恩·金基的尸体被发现时，这个12岁的女孩仍然穿着她的阳光海滩学校校服裙、粉红色的袜子和白色的运动鞋。她被割破的内衣在附近被发现，她的绿色书包则在10米外的一个灌木丛中被找到。溪流附近的一小块空地看起来最近被人动过。她身下的草呈方形被压平，表明那里最近发生过什么事。
Shang had been sexually assaulted, strangled, and at the end of her ordeal, stabbed 12 times, with two deep cuts across her throat. Sombra detectives at the crime scene thoroughly examined the area, their eyes damp with tears. There was no sign of the murder weapon, nor any other evidence to answer two of the most significant questions, who and why. Despite all hope and efforts to find Shang Kingi before she had come to any harm, her missing person case had now shifted into a homicide investigation. Although devastated at the outcome, Linda Kingi said she was grateful that her daughter's body was found. Quote, We know she is at rest, and nobody can hurt her anymore.
肖恩曾遭性侵、勒死，并在受虐结束后被刺了12刀，喉咙上有两处深深的伤口。犯罪现场的索姆布拉（Sombra）侦探仔细检查了该地区，眼里含着泪水。没有发现凶器，也没有任何其他证据来回答两个最重要的问题：是谁，为什么。尽管付出了所有的希望和努力，试图在肖恩·金基遭受任何伤害之前找到她，但她的失踪案现在已经变成了凶杀案调查。尽管对结果感到痛心，但琳达·金基表示，她很感激找到了女儿的尸体。“我们知道她已经安息了，没有人能再伤害她了。”
The Kingi's remained stoic and dignified, holding themselves together for the sake of their younger child, Shang's little brother. They expressed gratitude for the ongoing hard work of police and media, and on some evenings brought dinner for the overworked detectives who were tirelessly searching for their daughter's killer. Five days after Shang was found, her family and friends gathered for a memorial service to celebrate the short, though impactful life of the popular, kind-hearted preteen. In acknowledgement of her New Zealand heritage, Shang was given a traditional Maori farewell, woven with elements from her Australian upbringing. The song Imagine by John Lennon played, the lyrics encouraging mourners to envision the world as unified in peace and harmony.
金基夫妇表现得坚忍而尊严，为了他们的小儿子——肖恩的小弟弟，他们强打精神。他们对警方和媒体坚持不懈的辛勤工作表示感谢，甚至在某些晚上给那些疲惫不堪、不知疲倦地寻找他们女儿杀手侦探送去晚餐。在肖恩被找到五天后，她的家人和朋友聚集在一起举行追悼会，庆祝这位广受欢迎、心地善良的青春期前女孩短暂却影响力深遠的一生。为了承认她的新西兰血统，肖恩得到了传统的毛利人告别仪式，其中交织了她澳大利亚成长经历的元素。播放了约翰·列农（John Lennon）的歌曲《想象》（Imagine），歌词鼓励哀悼者设想一个在和平与和谐中统一的世界。
Shang was often regarded for her pixie-like personality and appearance, with her girlish looks, free spirit, and wide, endearing smile. One of Shang's school friends read a piece from the fable Peter Pan, in which the forever young character of Peter explains where fairies originated from. When the first child laughed for the first time, its laugh broke into a thousand pieces and went skipping about, and that was the beginning of fairies. Detective Sergeant Bob Atkinson and senior members of the Homicide Squad took a brief break from their hunt to find Shang's killer to attend the young girl's service and pay their respects. Upon the discovery of Shang King's body, Nusa Detective soon received the photographs of their
肖恩常常因其小精灵般的个性和外表而备受赞誉，她有着少女般的容貌、自由的精神和迷人的灿烂笑容。肖恩的一位学校朋友朗读了寓言《彼得·潘》中的一段，其中永远年轻的彼得解释了仙女的起源。当第一个孩子第一次笑时，她的笑声碎成了一千块，四处蹦跳，这就是仙女的开始。警长鲍勃·阿金森和凶杀组的高级成员们短暂地从搜寻肖恩凶手的行动中抽身，出席了这位年轻女孩的追悼会并表达敬意。在发现肖恩·金基尸体后不久，努萨侦探收到了他们锁定的
two persons of interest, Barry Watts and Valme Beck. The owners of a white 1973 Holden Kingswood station wagon, witnessed in the vicinity of Pinaroo Park at the time Shang was last seen alive. The pictures depicted a 33-year-old Barry John Watts, a slim, short-statured man of tanned complexion, with tattoos inked down his forearms and biceps, as well as his wife, 43-year-old Valme Faye Beck, a matronly woman with pasty pale skin and short, wiry hair. The photographs were accompanied by a note explaining that the couple had outstanding warrants after skipping bail in Western Australia. Barry Watts had failed to appear in court on an armed robbery charge, and Valme Beck was wanted for a string of burglaries and obtaining money
两名嫌疑人巴里·沃茨（Barry Watts）和瓦尔梅·贝克（Valme Beck）的照片。他们是一辆白色1973年霍顿·金斯伍德旅行车的车主，该车在肖恩最后一次被活着看到的时候曾在皮纳鲁公园附近出现过。照片显示，33岁的巴里·约翰·沃茨（Barry John Watts）身材瘦削、个子不高、肤色晒黑，前臂和二头肌上文有纹身；还有他的妻子，43岁的瓦尔梅·法伊·贝克（Valme Faye Beck），一个面色苍白、留着短而硬的头发的胖女人。照片附有一张便条，解释说这对夫妇在西澳大利亚州保释潜逃后背负着未执行的逮捕令。巴里·沃茨因武装抢劫指控未按时出庭，瓦尔梅·贝克则因一连串入室盗窃和以虚假借口骗取钱财而被通缉。
under false pretenses. Investigators for the Shang King homicide investigation put out a bulletin describing Watts, Beck and their station wagon to every police station throughout Queensland. On Tuesday, December 8, off-duty Detective Constable Graham Hall decided to make an impromptu visit to his office at the Ipswich Criminal Investigation Branch. He noticed the bulletin from Nusa police informing officers to be on the lookout for Barry Watts and Valme Beck, wanted for questioning in relation to the murder of Shang King. When Hall read the description of the wanted couple's white 1973 Holden Kingswood station wagon and saw its license plate number, LLE-429, his body tensed. The number only differed by a letter
肖恩·金基凶杀案调查人员发布了一份通告，向昆士兰州的所有警察局描述了沃茨、贝克以及他们的旅行车。12月8日星期二，休班警员格雷厄姆·霍尔（Graham Hall）决定临时访问他在伊普斯威奇刑事调查分局的办公室。他注意到了努萨警方发出的通告，通知警官们注意寻找巴里·沃茨和瓦尔梅·贝克，他们因涉嫌谋杀肖恩·金基而被通缉讯问。当霍尔读到被通缉的这对夫妇的白色1973年霍顿·金斯伍德旅行车的描述并看到其车牌号LLE-429时，他的身体紧绷了起来。这个号码只有一个字母之差
and digit from those supplied to him by Cheryl Mortimer and Nicole Close. They were two of three young, local Ipswich women who had been the targets of botched abduction attempts in early November by an unknown man driving a white station wagon. Detective Constable Hall and his colleagues had taken every effort to search for the alleged abductor at the time of these attacks. Unfortunately, the victims had misread the perpetrator's license plate. But similarities between their recollections of the plate, suggested they were close to identifying the correct number. Police searched countless combinations of those digits and letters in databases,
以及切丽·莫蒂默和妮可·克罗斯提供给他的数字。她们是伊普斯威奇的三名年轻本地女性中的两人，在11月上旬曾成为一个驾驶白色旅行车的陌生男子拙劣绑架未遂的目标。霍尔警长和他的同事在这些袭击发生时曾尽一切努力搜寻所谓的绑架者。不幸的是，受害者记错了作案者的车牌。但她们对车牌的回忆之间的相似之处表明，她们已经接近确定正确的号码。警方在数据库中搜索了这些数字和字母无数的组合，
their search failing to find a registration associated with a Holden Kingswood station wagon. With the realisation the Ipswich attacker may have been the same person who targeted Shang King in Nusa weeks later, Detective Constable Hall was overcome with guilt. Had they successfully traced the plate in early November and tracked down its owner, Shang King might have made the short bike ride home that Friday afternoon. Hall immediately phoned detectives in Nusa to notify them of the link. He then requested Cheryl Mortimer, Nicole Close and the other nurse who had a close encounter with the unidentified man in Ipswich to urgently come to the station for further questioning.
他们的搜索未能找到与霍顿金斯伍德旅行车相关的登记信息。意识到伊普斯威奇的袭击者可能就是几周后在努萨针对尚·金的同一个人，霍尔警长内心充满了内疚。如果他们在11月上旬成功追踪到车牌并找到车主，尚·金可能就不会在那个星期五下午进行那次短途的自行车骑行回家。霍尔立即打电话给努萨的侦探通知他们这一联系。随后，他要求切丽·莫蒂默、妮可·克罗斯以及另一位在伊普斯威奇与不明男子有密切接触的护士紧急赶往警察局接受进一步讯问。
All three of the women were presented with a line-up of photos and asked to point out the man who had confronted them. Each one identified Barry Watts as their assailant and in the case of Cheryl Mortimer, who was attacked by both a man and a woman, she pointed out Watts accomplice as Valme Beck. The bloody fingerprint left by the perpetrator on Cheryl's car window was a match to Prince in Barry Watts' criminal record. It was clear Barry Watts, with the assistance of his wife Valme Beck, had attempted to abduct the Ipswich women. Furthermore, the couple's vehicle was witnessed in the vicinity of Piniru Park at the time 12-year-old Shang King was last seen alive.
这三名女性都被出示了一组照片，并被要求指出面对过她们的男子。每个人都认出巴里·瓦茨是她们的袭击者；而在遭到一个男人和一个女人袭击的切丽·莫蒂默的案例中，她指认瓦茨的同伙是瓦尔梅·贝克。凶手留在切丽汽车车窗上的血手印与巴里·瓦茨犯罪记录中的指纹相符。很明显，巴里·瓦茨在妻子瓦尔梅·贝克的协助下，曾试图绑架伊普斯威奇的女性。此外，在12岁女孩尚·金最后一次被活着看到的时候，这对夫妇的车辆曾被目击出现在皮鲁公园附近。
Police were certain they were hot on the heels of Shang's killers. They put out an Australian-wide bulletin requesting police officers in every state be on the lookout for Barry Watts, Valme Beck and their vehicle. At 4pm, the bulletin reached the local police station in the small, inland Queensland town of Lowood, located on the Brisbane River, 200 kilometres south of Noosa. Constable John Stare had finished up his shift and was almost out the door when he was alerted to the announcement that police in Noosa were searching for a white Holden Kingswood station wagon with Victorian license plates. Constable Stare had spotted a vehicle just like it
警方确信他们正在紧追尚的杀手不放。他们发布了一份全澳大利亚范围的通告，要求各州的警官密切留意巴里·瓦茨、瓦尔梅·贝克以及他们的车辆。下午4点，这份通告传到了昆士兰州内陆小镇洛伍德的当地警察局，该镇位于布里斯班河畔，在努萨以南200公里处。约翰·斯泰尔警员已经完成了值班，正准备出门，这时他接到警报称，努萨警方正在寻找一辆挂着维多利亚州车牌的白色霍顿金斯伍德旅行车。斯泰尔警员曾发现过一辆一模一样的车，
whilst patrolling the town during the week. In a small country town like Lowood, seeing an out-of-state vehicle was unusual enough that Stare had made a mental note of the first half of the station wagon's license plate, LLE. He immediately made a call to Noosa police to let them know what he had seen. On Wednesday, December 9, Detective Constable Graham Hall of the Ipswich Criminal Investigation Branch and a team of detectives from Noosa descended on Lowood. On the lookout for the most wanted vehicle in Australia. A quick drive through the small town of only 3,000 people quickly determined the white station wagon was not on the street or parked in public site. The detectives began methodically combing
那是他在一周内巡逻小镇时看到的。在洛伍德这样一个乡村小镇里，看到一辆外州牌照的车已经足够罕见，以至于斯泰尔记下了旅行车车牌的前半部分：LLE。他立即打电话给努萨警方，告知他们自己看到的情况。12月9日星期三，伊普斯威奇刑事调查分局的格雷厄姆·霍尔警长和来自努萨的一队侦探来到了洛伍德，寻找澳大利亚最通缉的车辆。驱车快速穿过这个只有3000人口的小镇后，很快确定那辆白色旅行车不在街上，也没有停在公共场所。侦探们开始有条不紊地搜查，
the town on foot, showing every business owner and a local resident pictures of the car and its owners in the hopes someone recognised the couple. On the following evening, Thursday, December 10, telephone service employee Colin Harme was having a drink at his favourite pub in Lowood when the barman brought up the topic of the wanted couple and the ongoing search for their vehicle. The conversation sparked Colin's memory. He had recently seen a white Holden Kingswood station wagon with Victorian license plates parked in the yard of a house in Lowood while he was working up a telephone pole. He had taken special note of the car as he had been thinking of buying a similar model and remembered exactly which house it was out in front of. The next morning,
在镇上步行，向每位企业主和当地居民展示该车及其车主的照片，希望有人能认出这对夫妇。第二天晚上，即12月10日星期星期四，电信服务员工科林·哈姆正在洛伍德他最喜欢的酒吧喝酒，酒保提起了被通缉的夫妇以及对他们车辆持续搜寻的话题。这次对话唤起了科林的记忆。他最近在电线杆上工作时，曾看到一辆挂着维多利亚州车牌的白色霍顿金斯伍德旅行车停在洛伍德一栋房子的院子里。他特别注意了这辆车，因为他当时正考虑买一款类似的型号，并且清楚地记得它停在哪栋房子前面。第二天早上，
Colin Harme led police to an A-frame house on an acre block. The white station wagon was no longer parked in the yard and nobody appeared to be home. Police door knocked nearby houses and questioned neighbours who all had vivid recollections of the vehicle due to the frequency with which the man of the house washed it. They also mentioned the same man had been making questionable approaches towards passing school girls. When presented with a book of mug shots, the neighbours identified both Barry Watts and Valme Beck as living at the property. A local real estate agency confirmed that Barry Watts and Valme Beck's names were on the lease of the Lowood property and police obtained a search warrant for the house. When they entered the residence, no one was inside. Police found
科林·哈姆带着警察来到了一栋占地一英亩的A字形房子。那辆白色旅行车已经不在院子里了，而且看起来也没有人在家。警察敲了附近房子的门，盘问了邻居们，由于男主人洗车的频率很高，他们对这辆车都有清晰的记忆。他们还提到同一个男主人曾对路过的女学生进行过可疑的搭讪。当看到一本嫌疑人照片集时，邻居们确认巴里·瓦茨和瓦尔梅·贝克住在该房产内。当地一家房地产中介证实，巴里·瓦茨和瓦尔梅·贝克的名字在洛伍德房产的租赁合同上，警方获得了该房屋的搜查令。当他们进入住所时，里面空无一人。警察发现
empty packets of hair dye in the rubbish bin and evidence indicating that the couple had left in a hurry. A rolled up newspaper on the kitchen floor was dated the previous Friday, December 4th. Police had missed the fugitives by a week. No evidence was found in the house to reveal the couple's current whereabouts. Detective Constable Graham Hall asked the Lowood real estate agency if they could provide any further information that might help locate Watts and Beck. He was in luck. A rent payment had just come in from the pair via a money order. It had arrived from the entrance, a holiday resort town on the New South Wales coast, over 800 kilometres away from Lowood. Detective Constable Hall relayed his
垃圾桶里有空的染发剂包装，有迹象表明这对夫妇走得很匆忙。厨房地板上卷起的一份报纸日期是前一周的12月4日星期五。警察与逃犯擦肩而过，晚了一周。屋里没有发现能够揭示这对夫妇目前行踪的证据。格雷厄姆·霍尔警长询问洛伍德房地产中介是否能提供任何有助于定位瓦茨和贝克的进一步信息。他运气不错。这对夫妇刚通过汇票支付了一笔房租。这笔钱来自新南威尔士州海岸的一个度假小镇——恩特伦斯，距离洛伍德800多公里。霍尔警长转述了他的
findings to Noosa Detective Sergeant Bob Atkinson with mounting excitement. They now had proof of Watts and Beck's whereabouts as recently as the previous day. Police in New South Wales were notified and acted swiftly, sending 10 plainclothes police officers into the small seaside town of the entrance to search for the wanted couple. They were advised to act with caution as they didn't want to alert the couple and give them any opportunity to flee. Police were also warned that Barry Watts was known to carry a firearm and may not surrender lightly. Within hours of descending on the entrance, an undercover officer spotted a white 1973 Holden Kingswood station wagon leaving a supermarket car park. Its Victorian license plates read LLE 429. Realising he had
发现给努萨侦探中士鲍勃·阿特金森，语气中带着越来越兴奋的情绪。他们现在有了瓦茨和贝克就在前一天还出现过的新证据。新南威尔士州警方接到通知并迅速行动，派遣了10名便衣警察前往小海滨镇恩特伦斯搜寻被通缉的夫妇。他们被告知行动要谨慎，因为不想惊动这对夫妇并给他们任何逃跑的机会。警方还警告说，巴里·瓦茨众所周知随身携带枪支，可能不会轻易投降。在抵达恩特伦斯几小时后，一名便衣警察发现一辆白色的1973年霍顿金斯伍德旅行车从超市停车场驶出。其维多利亚州车牌写着LLE 429。意识到自己
spotted Barry Watts and Valme Beck's car, the undercover officer discreetly tailed the vehicle down the entrance road until it pulled into a cheap motel on a busy intersection. The officer parked across the street and put in a call to the Noosa command centre, advising that he had the suspect vehicle under surveillance. Detective Sergeant Bob Atkinson, who had been fronting the investigation from the day her parents reported her missing, was on the next plane to Sydney to be present for the arrest of the 12-year-old's killers. At 5pm on Saturday December 12, nine days after Sean Kingey was found murdered, police circled the ground floor motel unit believed to be occupied by Barry Watts and Valme Beck. Using a master key supplied by the motel
发现了巴里·瓦茨和瓦尔梅·贝克的车，便衣警察谨慎地尾随这辆车沿着恩特伦斯路行驶，直到它驶入繁华路口的一家廉价汽车旅馆。这名警察将车停在街对面，并致电努萨指挥中心，通报他正在对嫌疑车辆进行监视。自女孩父母报告她失踪之日起就一直负责调查的侦探中士鲍勃·阿特金森搭乘了飞往悉尼的下一班飞机，准备亲临现场逮捕这名12岁女孩的凶手。12月12日星期星期六下午5点，即肖恩·金吉被发现遇害九天后，警察包围了据信被巴里·瓦茨和瓦尔梅·贝克占据的汽车旅馆一楼房间。使用汽车旅馆提供的万能钥匙
manager, officers burst in on the room and confronted Watts and Beck inside. Fears of a potential shootout immediately subsided when the couple offered no resistance and were arrested without incident. Police brought the pair to the local police station, separated them and launched into interrogations. Barry Watts, seasoned career criminal, knew no good could ever come from talking to the police. He refused to provide his name and shook his head when asked whether the mugshot they had was a picture of him. Watts denied having ever been in Noosa, claiming to have just travelled up to Lowwood from Melbourne where the pair had lived for the past 10 years. It was an obvious lie as investigators were aware Watts and Beck had skipped a bail in Western Australia
经理和警官们冲进房间，与里面的瓦茨和贝克对质。这对夫妇没有反抗，波澜不惊地被捕，对潜在枪战的恐惧瞬间消散。警察将二人带到当地警察局，将他们分开并开始审讯。巴里·瓦茨是一个经验丰富的职业罪犯，深知跟警察说话绝没有好下场。他拒绝透露自己的姓名，当被问及他们手头的面部照片是不是他时，他摇了摇头。瓦茨否认自己去过努萨，声称自己刚刚从墨尔本一路北上来到洛伍德，他们过去10年一直住在墨尔本。这是一个显而易见的谎言，因为调查人员知道瓦茨和贝克在西澳大利亚州曾弃保潜逃
and were on the run. Meanwhile, in a separate interrogation room, Valme Beck provided police with a story which placed the couple in Noosa on the day of Sean's murder. Beck claimed the couple spent the day of Friday November 27 drinking and arguing before she stormed off in anger. Barry Watts then drove to Noosa where he slept for a couple of hours before returning to pick up his wife and take her home to Lowwood. When the couple were reunited in the police station, they gave nothing away. Valme Beck sat on Barry Watts' lap and the two smoked cigarettes, kissed and chatted as if they didn't have a care in the world. As Beck was led away for further questioning, Watts told his wife to stick by him. She promised she would.
并且正在逃亡途中。与此同时，在另一个审讯室里，瓦尔梅·贝克向警方供述了一个说辞，将这对夫妇置于肖恩谋杀案当天的努萨。贝克声称，这对夫妇在11月27日星期五那天度过了一天，一直在喝酒和争吵，后来她愤怒地摔门而去。巴里·瓦茨随后开车前往努萨，在那里睡了几个小时，然后回来接他的妻子并带她回洛伍德。当这对夫妇在警察局重聚时，他们什么也没有泄露。瓦尔梅·贝克坐在巴里·瓦茨的腿上，两人抽着烟、接吻、闲聊，仿佛世上没有让他们操心的事。当贝克被带走接受进一步审讯时，瓦茨告诉他的妻子要坚定地支持他。她答应了。
Valme Faye Beck was born in 1943 to a family dominated by a cold, unloving matriarch who would offload young Valme onto any relatives who would take her. Valme's three brothers ran wild and were not protective of their little sister. If no relatives were available to watch over Valme, she was left in the company of strangers, some of whom subjected her to sexual abuse. By the time she was 12 years old, Valme had been pulled out of school by her mother and sent to work in a clothing factory so she could pay her own way. Three years later, when Valme was 15, she was registered as a neglected child and committed to the care of the state. Between 1961 and 1972, Valme was in and out of prison on a variety of
瓦尔梅·费伊·贝克于1943年出生在一个由一位冷酷、毫无爱心的女家长统治的家庭里，这位母亲会把年幼的瓦尔梅甩给任何愿意收留她的亲戚。瓦尔梅的三个兄弟野蛮生长，并不保护他们的小妹妹。如果没有亲戚能照看瓦尔梅，她就会被留给陌生人陪伴，其中一些人对她实施了性虐待。到她12岁时，瓦尔梅被母亲拉出学校，送到一家服装厂工作，以便她能自食其力。三年后，当瓦尔梅15岁时，她被登记为被忽视儿童，并被交由国家监护。在1961年至1972年期间，瓦尔梅因各种
offences. She changed her name periodically and drifted between menial jobs. Regarded as uneducated and unlikable, Valme Beck nevertheless married twice and gave birth to six children from at least two men. She harboured little to no maternal instincts. Her children were either taken away by authorities and made into wards of the state or put into the custody of their fathers and raised elsewhere. Valme spent much of her time in seedy bars run by staff who allowed her to keep drinking long after she should have been cut off. By 1983, she was a foul mouth drunk with children and a grandchild she very rarely saw, living in one of the down-and-out suburbs of Perth, Western Australia. It was in one of Perth's dingy pubs that Valme was introduced to Barry Watts, a man 10 years her
犯罪屡次进出监狱。她定期改名，在低级的工作之间漂泊。瓦尔梅·贝克被认为没受过教育且令人讨厌，但她还是结过两次婚，并为至少两个男人生下了六个孩子。她几乎没有或根本没有母性本能。她的孩子要么被当局带走成为国家受抚养人，要么被交由他们的父亲抚养并在别处抚养长大。瓦尔梅的大部分时间都在肮脏的酒吧里度过，酒吧的工作人员允许她一直喝酒，哪怕她早就该被拒之门外了。到1983年，她是一个满嘴脏话的酒鬼，有孩子和一个她极少见到的孙辈，住在西澳大利亚州珀斯的一个破落郊区。正是在珀斯的一家破旧酒吧里，瓦尔梅经人介绍认识了比她小
junior. Barry, an orphan, had an equally troubling childhood and was now making his way as a career criminal. The two bonded over stories of their time spent in prison. Valme told Barry about the time she befriended Catherine Burney, a fellow inmate in a Western Australian prison. Catherine Burney was incarcerated for the abduction, rape and murders of four women, crimes she committed with her husband David, covered in case 31 of case file. During their time incarcerated together, Catherine Burney allegedly told Valme Beck that having sex while murdering a female was the greatest thrill of all. Barry Watts listened to this story with great interest. Valme Beck and Barry Watts started a relationship, falling into a habit of alcoholic benders,
10岁的巴里·瓦茨。巴里是个孤儿，有着同样令人烦恼的童年，现在正以职业罪犯的身份谋生。两人因他们在监狱里度过的时光的故事而结缘。瓦尔梅向巴里讲述了她与凯瑟琳·伯尼交朋友的经历，凯瑟琳是西澳大利亚州一所监狱里的同狱犯人。凯瑟琳·伯尼因绑架、强奸和谋杀四名女性而被监禁，这些罪行是她与丈夫大卫一起犯下的，这在案卷第31案中有所涵盖。在他们一起服刑期间，凯瑟琳·伯尼据称告诉瓦尔梅·贝克，在谋杀女性的同时发生性关系是最大的刺激。巴里·瓦茨听了这个故事非常感兴趣。瓦尔梅·贝克和巴里·瓦茨开始了一段恋情，陷入了酗酒狂欢的习惯中，
drinking in squalid dive bars until they were kicked out and to then carrying on in a local park until they passed out, only to wake up and do it all again the next day. It was assorted destructive relationship punctuated by verbal and physical abuse. Despite their toxic pairing, Valme was desperate to hang on to the one man who seemed willing to maintain a relationship with her. In 1986, the couple married in Perth when Valme was 43 and Barry was 33. Valme took the surname of Barry's adoptive father, Beck. Even when they had been able to find work despite their extensive criminal records, neither Valme Beck nor Barry Watts were able to hold down jobs for long.
在肮脏不堪的小酒馆里酗酒，直到被赶出去，接着又到当地的公园里喝到不省人事，醒来后第二天周而复始。这段充满破坏性的关系中交织着言语和肢体虐待。尽管这段关系有毒，瓦尔米却拼命想要抓住这个似乎愿意与她保持关系的男人。1986年，两人在珀斯结婚，当时瓦尔米43岁，巴里33岁。瓦尔米随了巴里养父的姓氏——贝克。尽管由于他们有大量犯罪前科而很难找到工作，但瓦尔米·贝克和巴里·瓦茨都无法长久保住工作。
Instead, they turned to crime and social security fraud to fund their drinking binges. Barry would break into cars to steal passbooks and Valme would practice copying the owner's signature until it was close enough that she could fraudulently withdraw money from the victim's bank account. By 1987, both Valme Beck and Barry Watts were out on bail on charges that would most certainly carry lengthy jail sentences given their criminal records. Perth had become too hot for them, so they fled to the other side of the country, laying low at Barry's adoptive father's house in Victoria. They eventually swapped their old sedan for a 1973 Holden Kingswood station wagon, a car that was big enough for the two to sleep in when they were on the road.
相反，他们通过犯罪和欺诈社会保障金来资助他们的大吃大喝。巴里会撬车偷取存折，而瓦尔米则会练习模仿车主的签名，直到足以从受害者的银行账户中诈骗取款。到了1987年，瓦尔米·贝克和巴里·瓦茨都因面临极可能导致长期监禁的指控而在保释期间。珀斯对他们来说已经变得不再安全，于是他们逃到了国家的另一端，在巴里位于维多利亚州的养父家里低调藏身。他们最终用旧轿车换了一辆1973年的霍顿·金斯伍德旅行车，这辆车足够大，供他们在路上时睡在里面。
The couple knew it was only a matter of time before police came looking for them, so they headed north to the warmer tropical climate, with no plan on where they would stop. After a rambling trip that took them through New South Wales and over the Queensland border, the couple settled in the town of Lowood. The day after the couple's arrest, Detective Sergeant Bob Atkinson escorted Barry Watts and Valme Beck on a plane back to Queensland and put them into adjoining cells in the Noosa police station lockup. Unbeknownst to Watts or Beck, police had obtained a warrant to place covert electronic listening devices into their cells to monitor and record everything the couple said.
这对夫妇知道警方找上门只是时间问题，于是他们向北前往更温暖的热带气候，对在哪里停下没有任何计划。经过一段漫长的旅程，穿过新南威尔士州并越过昆士兰州边境后，这对夫妇在洛伍德镇安顿下来。这对夫妇被捕的第二天，侦探警长鲍勃·阿特金森押送巴里·瓦茨和瓦尔米·贝克乘飞机返回昆士兰州，并将他们关押在努萨警察局的相邻牢房里。瓦茨和贝克并不知道，警方已经获得了在他们的牢房里安隐蔽电子监听设备的搜查令，以监控和记录这对夫妇所说的一切。
A conversation between the pair revealed that the story Valme Beck had told investigators about the pair's movements on Friday, November 27, was actually prefabricated and rehearsed. Despite having helped fabricate the story, Barry Watts expressed anger at his wife for telling police he was in Noosa, and thus placing him at the location of Sean Kingey's abduction at the time she went missing. Although they made some other cryptic references to their activities, the couple said nothing implicating them in Sean's murder. Detective Sergeant Atkinson believed he had a better chance of extracting information from Valme Beck rather than her stoic, tight-lipped husband. Thus, Atkinson began the mentally challenging task of befriending
两人的对话表明，瓦尔米·贝克此前向调查人员讲述的关于两人在11月27日星期五的行踪其实是事先编造和排练过的。尽管参与了故事的编造，但巴里·瓦茨还是对妻子告诉警方他在努萨感到愤怒，从而将自己置于肖恩·金吉被绑架时她失踪的地点。尽管他们对自己的活动做了一些其他神秘的暗示，但这对夫妇没有说任何能证明他们参与肖恩谋杀案的话。侦探警长阿特金森认为，从瓦尔米·贝克那里获取信息的机会比从她那冷漠、口风紧的丈夫那里获取信息的机会更大。于是，阿特金森开始了与她建立友谊这一充满精神挑战的任务
Valme, despite feeling repulsed by the woman he strongly suspected was involved in Sean's murder. He told Beck about all the evidence they had compiled, building a damning case against her husband. He also told Beck he was sure she hadn't meant to cause Sean Kingey any harm. Valme continued to deny involvement in the crime, sticking to her original story about fighting with her husband and him retreating to Noosa for a few hours before returning to her. Yet, she added small details every time she was asked to retell her version of events. Detective Sergeant Atkinson lent Beck a patient sympathetic ear, latching on to her insecurities about her marriage and gently establishing a rapport with the woman.
瓦尔米，尽管他内心对这个被他强烈怀疑与肖恩谋杀案有关的女人感到反感。他向贝克讲述了他们收集的所有证据，建立起针对她丈夫的不利证据。他还告诉贝克，他确信她并不是故意伤害肖恩·金吉的。瓦尔米继续否认自己参与了这起犯罪，坚持她最初的说法，即与丈夫争吵，丈夫独自前往努萨几个小时后才回到她身边。然而，每次被要求重新讲述她的版本时，她都会补充一些微小的细节。侦探警长阿特金森耐心地倾听贝克的诉说，抓住了她对婚姻的不安全感，并温柔地与这个女人建立起了融洽的关系。
Eventually, his efforts paid off, and as he anticipated, Valme Beck broke completely. She spoke for seven hours straight, stopping only to drink water, go to the toilet, or consume the chocolate the detective said she demanded they bring to her. By the time she had finished talking, Valme Beck's complete statement filled over 29 pages. According to Beck, her husband Barry Watts had a fixation for younger women, amassing a large collection of pornography that featured teenage girls or adult actresses posing as teens. Watts would compare his wife, whom he criticised for being overweight and old, to younger, prettier girls.
最终，他的努力得到了回报，正如他所料，瓦尔米·贝克彻底崩溃了。她连续讲了七个小时，只停下来喝水、上厕所，或者吃侦探说她要求带给她的巧克力。当她讲完时，瓦尔米·贝克的完整供词写了满满29页。据贝克交代，她的丈夫巴里·瓦茨对年轻女性有着特殊的执念，收藏了大量以十几岁女孩或扮演青少年的成年女演员为主角的色情制品。瓦茨会将妻子与更年轻、更漂亮的女孩进行比较，并批评妻子又胖又老。
Whenever Beck bought that one of Watts' demands, he would threaten to leave her for someone younger and slimmer, feeding her deepest insecurities. She seethed with jealousy as she watched her husband obsess over young teens, but she also harboured a sense of voyeurism. During the couple's move from Victoria to Lowwood in Queensland, Barry Watts left his beloved pornography collection behind. To get his kicks, he would instead loiter outside and gawk at high school girls walking home in their uniforms.
每当贝克满足沃茨的一个要求时，他就会威胁要离开她去找一个更年轻、更苗条的人，这触及了她内心最深的不安全感。当她看着丈夫痴迷于年轻女孩时，她嫉妒得怒火中烧，但她心里也隐藏着一种偷窥的快感。在两人从维多利亚州搬到昆士兰州洛伍德的过程中，巴里·沃茨落下了他心爱的色情收藏。为了寻求刺激，他转而闲逛并在路边傻看着穿着校服走回家的女高中生。
Watts knew his wife felt increasingly threatened by his deviant desires, and had used her paranoia and low self-esteem as a form of control. He would threaten to leave her, just like her previous two husbands had, fuelling Beck's insecurities and ensuring she remained passive in their dysfunctional marriage. When it was clear he had established a hold over his wife, Watts told Beck about his fantasy of having sex with a young female virgin. When Beck complained about her husband's desire to be unfaithful, Watts told her there was one way she could ensure his fidelity to her forever.
沃茨知道他的妻子对他的变态欲望越来越感到威胁，并利用她的多疑和低自尊作为一种控制手段。他威胁要离开她，就像她之前的两个丈夫做的那样，这加剧了贝克的不安全感，并确保她在他们功能失调的婚姻中保持被动。当确定自己已经控制了妻子后，沃茨向贝克吐露了他想和年轻女处女性交的幻想。当贝克抱怨丈夫想要不忠的欲望时，沃茨告诉她，有一个办法可以让她确保他对她永远忠诚。
Help him abduct a young virgin for one single act of sadistic pleasure, getting the desire out of his system once and for all. Beck agreed to do as her husband asked, even when he indicated that their chosen victim would not survive the ordeal, telling his wife, quote, I will be the first and last man she ever has. When fueled by alcohol-induced courage, Watts made his wife drive out into distant neighborhoods to help him look for vulnerable young women.
帮他绑架一个年轻处女，进行一次虐待性的快感宣泄，彻底消除他心中的欲望。贝克同意按丈夫的要求去做，甚至当他暗示他们挑选的受害者将无法在劫难中幸存时，他对妻子说，原句是，我会成为她拥有的第一个也是最后一个男人。在酒精带来的勇气的驱使下，沃茨让他的妻子开车去偏远的社区帮他寻找年轻脆弱的女性。
Val made Beck confess to investigators that she had assisted her husband in his failed attempts to kidnap Cheryl Mortimer, Nicole Close, and the other female nursing hip switch in early November. On Friday, November 27, 1987, Barry Watts told Val made Beck, Today is the day. After drinking heavily, the couple traveled to the coastal town of Noosa over 200 kilometers away from their home in Lowwood. Certain the warm day would attract an abundance of young girls to the local beaches.
瓦尔逼迫贝克向调查人员供认，她在11月初协助丈夫对切尔西·莫蒂默、妮可·科尔斯和其他几名女护士实施了未遂绑架。1987年11月27日，星期五，巴里·沃茨对瓦尔梅·贝克说，就是今天。在痛饮一番后，夫妻俩前往距离洛伍德家中200多公里外的沿海小镇努沙。他们确信这个温暖的日子会吸引大量年轻女孩来到当地海滩。
They began trawling Noosa's streets and shores, but the women they spotted were either too old for Watts or not alone. Frustrated, Watts started arguing with his wife and drove off on his own, leaving her behind. Unable to give up on his evil plan, Watts continued the search for his victim, Solo, trudging the sand dunes along Castaway's beach. But he soon realized it would be far easier for him to abduct his victim with his wife's assistance, as young girls would be more likely to trust and approach a motherly middle-aged woman.
他们开始在努沙的街道和海岸搜寻，但他们发现的女性要么对沃茨来说年龄太大，要么不是独身一人。受挫的沃茨开始和妻子争吵，并独自开车离开，把她抛在了身后。沃茨无法放弃他邪恶的计划，继续独自一人寻找目标，在卡斯特韦海滩的沙丘中艰难跋涉。但他很快意识到，如果有他妻子的协助，绑架受害者会容易得多，因为年轻女孩更有可能信任并接近一个慈祥的中年妇女。
When Watts reappeared to pick up Beck, she was grateful, forever paranoid that at any moment he would make a good on his threat and leave her forever. By dusk, the couple still hadn't found their eyes. The couple still hadn't found their ideal victim. Beck tried to reassure her increasingly incensed husband that his fantasy would be fulfilled, suggesting they get out of the car to stretch their legs on a walk around Piniru Park. There, Beck spotted a tall, blonde-haired girl wearing a school uniform, peddling towards them on a yellow bike.
当沃茨折返来接贝克时，她心存感激，内心永远 paranoid（多疑），担心他随时会兑现威胁并永远离开她。到了黄昏，这对夫妇依然没有找到他们的目标。这对夫妇依然没有找到他们理想的受害者。贝克试图安慰她那日益愤怒的丈夫，向他保证他的幻想会实现，建议他们下车在皮尼鲁公园附近散步舒展筋骨。在那里，贝克发现了一个高个子、金发、穿着校服的女孩，正骑着一辆黄色自行车朝他们蹬来。
Urging Watts to duck from sight, Beck plastered a look of concern on her face as the girl rode closer, and motioned at her to stop. Sensing no danger, Sean Kingey clutched the brakes on her bike and came to a stop before Valme Beck. Feigning concern, Beck made up a fictitious story that she had lost her dog in the park, a little poodle with a cute pink bow, asking Sean for assistance finding it. Sean dismounted her bike immediately, laying it on the edge of the path. Beck pointed in the direction her fictional poodle had gone,
贝克催促沃茨躲藏起来，当女孩骑近时，她的脸上堆满了关切的表情，并示意她停下来。肖·金吉没有感觉到危险，便捏住自行车的刹车，在瓦尔梅·贝克面前停了下来。贝克假装关心，编造了一个虚假的故事，说她在公园里弄丢了狗，是一只系着可爱粉红色蝴蝶结的小贵宾犬，并向肖寻求帮助寻找它。肖立刻下了车，把自行车放倒在小路边缘。贝克指着她那只虚构的贵宾犬走过方向，
and Sean peered into the thick bushes to see if she could spot the lost pup. Barry Watts then sprang from the bushes, grabbing Sean roughly from behind. He bundled her into the back seat of his station wagon, holding her down and out of sight. He bound her wrists and ankles with rope, and covered her mouth with brown duct tape. Beck jumped in the front seat and took the wheel. Watts made no attempt to cover Sean's eyes or disguise his own face, confident the girl would never be able to report his crime. They drove about 15km inland before turning down a secluded road leading through Timbira
肖探头窥视着浓密的灌木丛，想看看能不能找到那只走失的小狗。接着，巴里·沃茨从灌木丛中猛地窜出来，从后面粗暴地抓住了肖。他把她塞进旅行车的后座，把她按倒并挡住视线。他用绳子捆住她的手腕和脚踝，并用棕色电工胶带封住她的嘴。贝克跳上副驾驶座并握住了方向盘。沃茨没有试图遮挡肖的眼睛或伪装自己的脸，他坚信这个女孩永远无法报案。他们向内陆开 了大约15公里，然后驶入一条穿过廷比拉的偏僻公路
Mountain State Forest, stopping the car about 2km into the dense woodlands. Barry Watts pulled out a large bedspread from the back of the station wagon, and laid it out in a small, grassy clearing by Castaway's Creek. He told his wife to be careful getting Sean out of the car and removing the ropes and tape, so as not to leave any marks on her body or disturb her long blonde hair. In a soothing voice, Valmer Beck coaxed Sean to obey, reassuring her that if she did as she was told, she wouldn't get hurt. After untying her, Beck led Sean to the bedspread,
山地森林，在密林中开了大约2公里后停下车。巴里·沃茨从旅行车后备箱里拉出一条大床单，把它铺在卡斯特韦溪边一块长满青草的小空地上。他告诉妻子在把肖抱下车以及解开绳子和胶带时要小心，以免在她身上留下任何痕迹或弄乱她长长的金发。瓦尔梅·贝克用柔和的声音哄肖服从，向她保证如果她照着说的做，就不会受到伤害。解开绳子后，贝克引导肖走到那张床单旁，
which was illuminated by the station wagon headlights. The area Watts had chosen to commit his crime was well traversed, meaning anyone passing through the forest could have easily spotted the headlights and stumbled across them. A busy highway was just 45m away, followed by a gas station a little further along. But trees obscured their view, and nobody saw or heard a thing. Around an hour later, Barry Watts ordered Sean to get dressed and lie face down, instructing his wife to fetch him a belt from the car. Valmer Beck brought him a belt as requested, but asked,
床单被旅行车的前灯照亮。沃茨选择犯罪的这个地方交通其实相当便利，这意味着任何穿过森林的人都很容易发现前灯并偶然撞见他们。一条繁忙的高速公路就在45米外，稍远一点还有一家加油站。但树木遮挡了他们的视线，没有人看到或听到任何动静。大约一个小时后，巴里·沃茨命令肖穿好衣服并脸朝下躺下，同时指示妻子去车里拿一条皮带。瓦尔梅·贝克如要求般给他拿来了一条皮带，但问道，
can't we just leave her and go? Watts replied, don't be so fucking stupid, I can't trust her not to give me up. It was around 7pm when Barry Watts dragged Sean's lifeless body a few meters off the creep bank and into nearby brush. Meanwhile, Valmer Beck wrapped up the knife, duct tape, rope and belt in the bedspread, placing the items in the station wagon. She then concealed Sean's personal belongings in the surrounding area, before the couple climbed back into their car and drove away. On their way back home, they pulled over briefly to throw the bedspread and its contents into
难道我们不能就这么放了她然后走吗？沃茨回答说，别他妈的那么蠢，我不能信任她不会把我供出来。大约晚上7点，巴里·沃茨把肖毫无生气的尸体拖到离溪岸几米远的附近灌木丛中。与此同时，瓦尔梅·贝克把床单里的刀子、电工胶带、绳子和皮带包裹起来，放进旅行车里。然后，她在周边地区藏好了肖的私人物品，随后两人重新上车并驱车离开。在回家的路上，他们短暂停车，把床单及其里面的东西扔进了
Six Mile Creek, located between Tawanton and Coroy. They stopped again in Brisbane to purchase milk and cat food, arriving back at their property in Lowwood at around 10pm. Valmer Beck put their dirty clothes in the washing machine and started to cry. Barry Watts comforted her, telling her not to be upset and complimenting her for doing a great job and being a good wife. They then had sex for the first time in a long while. Although Valmer Beck and Barry Watts were confident they hadn't been seen during the attack on Sean Kingey, they went to great lengths to avoid detection. Beck cut her husband's sun bleached hair short and dyed it brown, then bleached her own hair. They changed their
六英里溪，位于陶万顿和科罗伊之间。他们再次在布里斯班停留购买牛奶和猫粮，于晚上10点左右回到洛伍德的住所。瓦尔梅·贝克把脏衣服放进洗衣机，然后开始哭泣。巴里·沃茨安慰她，叫她不要难过，并称赞她做得很好，是个好妻子。随后，他们进行了很长一段时间以来的第一次性生活。尽管瓦尔梅·贝克和巴里·沃茨确信他们在袭击肖·金吉的过程中没有被人看到，但他们还是采取了极端措施来逃避侦查。贝克把丈夫被阳光晒成浅色的头发剪短并染成棕色，然后自己也把头发漂染了。他们改变了
clothing style so they wouldn't match any descriptions provided by potential witnesses and washed their car thoroughly inside and out to remove any evidence. Watts continued to reassure Beck that he didn't feel bad about the crime and neither should she. As the week wore on, Sean Kingey's disappearance remained a mystery to police and the killer couple started to relax. It wasn't until they heard news that Sean's body had been found and police were interested in speaking to the owner of a white station wagon that the pair became spooked. Watts and Beck hastily packed suitcases, got in their car and left Lowwood. They headed interstate towards Victoria, where they figured they would be able to
穿衣风格，以免与潜在目击者提供的任何特征相符，并彻底清洗了汽车的内内外外以清除任何证据。沃茨继续安慰贝克，说他对这起罪行并不感到内疚，她也不应该感到内疚。随着时间的推移，肖·金吉的失踪对警方来说依然是个谜，这对杀人夫妇开始放松下来。直到他们听到消息称肖的尸体被找到，并且警方对寻找一辆白色旅行车的车主感兴趣时，两人才惊慌失措。沃茨和贝克匆忙打包行李，上车离开了洛伍德。他们向州际公路驶去，目的地是维多利亚州，他们认为在那里可以
sell their car quickly for cash to avoid being caught. Knowing they needed to keep the station wagon off the highways while police were actively searching for it, the pair took long rural routes. After they passed over the border into New South Wales, they settled into a motel in the scenic seaside town of the entrance, about 100km north of Sydney. Together, they devised a story to tell police should they ever be questioned in relation to Sean's murder. Watts urged his wife to never confess, nor believe any story that he had confessed unless she heard it with her own ears. The rent on the couple's Lowwood property was due, and they planned to eventually return to the house once the public interest in Sean Kingey's
迅速将车脱手换成现金以避免被捕。由于知道在警方全力搜寻期间需要让旅行车远离高速公路，两人选择了偏远的乡村路线。在穿过边界进入新南威尔士州后，他们在一个风景优美的海滨小镇——入口镇的一家汽车旅馆安顿下来，该镇位于悉尼以北约100公里处。他们一起编造了一个故事，如果将来因肖的谋杀案被审讯时好讲给警察听。沃茨敦促他的妻子永远不要招供，也不要相信任何关于他已经招供的说法，除非她亲耳听到。他们洛伍德房产的租金到期了，他们计划等公众对肖·金吉的关注
murder faded and became another forgotten cold case. Not wanting the hassle of a real estate agent knocking on the door of their Lowwood house looking for rent and perhaps raising questions about the couple's unexplained absence, Watts and Beck sent a money order through to cover the payment, inadvertently creating a paper trail that led police right to them. After Valne Beck's confession for the abduction, rape and murder of Sean Kingey, she was returned to her cell. The covert listening devices recorded her telling her husband that she had made a confession. She said, quote, the only thing I didn't put in the statement was what happened between her and me. I just couldn't tell them that. Barry Watts responded,
谋杀案的热度消退并成为又一起被遗忘的悬案后，再搬回这所房子。由于不想应付房地产经纪人敲响他们洛伍德房子的门来催租，并可能引发对这对夫妇无故失踪的疑问，沃茨和贝克通过汇款单支付了租金，无意中留下了一条直接将警察引向他们的纸质证据链。在瓦尔尼·贝克对绑架、强奸和谋杀肖·金吉供认不讳后，她被送回了单人牢房。隐蔽的监听设备记录下她告诉丈夫她已经招供了。她说，原句是，我唯一没有放进声明里的，就是她和我的事。我就是没法告诉他们。巴里·沃茨回答说，
that's quite understandable. I'm glad you didn't. Police searched Six Mile Creek and recovered the discarded knife, duct tape, rope, belt and bedspread used in the crime. The tape still contained strands of Sean's distinctive golden hair. Investigators showed Barry Watts his wife's lengthy and incredibly detailed statement that implicated them both in Sean Kingey's murder. And although he was taken aback, he remained tight lipped. He barked at investigators, quote, you might know what happened, but you've got to prove it. When he was returned to his cell, Watts couldn't stop himself from flying off the handle at Beck for her betrayal. As soon as they were left alone, he grew out at her through
这完全可以理解。我很高兴你没说。警察搜查了六英里溪，找到了犯罪中使用的被丢弃的刀子、电工胶带、绳子、皮带和床单。胶带上仍然粘有肖标志性的金色头发。调查人员向巴里·沃茨展示了她妻子那份长篇且极其详细的供词，该供词将两人都牵连进肖·金吉的谋杀案中。尽管他大吃一惊，但他依然守口如瓶。他对调查人员咆哮道，原句是，你们可能知道发生了什么，但你们得证明它。当被送回牢房时，沃茨气急败坏，无法克制自己，因为贝克的背叛而对她大发雷霆。一旦他们单独在一起，他隔着
the wall, unaware of everything he said was being recorded. Watts, quote, you hung me, good on you, top wife. If you hadn't betrayed me, we could have got away with it. Beck, no jury in the land would have found us innocent. You know it, and I know it. Watts, no one saw us pick her up and throw her in the car. No one seen her in the car. No one seen us kill her. If you hadn't confessed, they didn't have a case. Over the following 20 hours, the two continued to incriminate themselves further. Valme Beck tried to convince her husband to plead insanity, telling him, quote, if you just listen to me, you will get out of it. I won't, but you will. I can't plead insanity, but you can. You're off your tap. Going out and raping somebody is one thing,
墙冲她大吼大叫，浑然不知自己所说的一切都被录了下来。沃茨说，原句，你把我害惨了，真棒啊，好妻子。如果你没有背叛我，我们本可以逃脱法网。贝克，全岛没有一个陪审团会判定我们无罪。你心知肚明，我也心知肚明。沃茨，没有人看到我们把她抱上车并扔进车里。没有人看到她在车里。没有人看到我们杀了她。如果你没有招供，他们根本没有案子。在随后的20个小时里，两人继续进一步自证其罪。瓦尔梅·贝克试图说服她的丈夫做精神错乱辩护，告诉他，原句，如果你听我的，你就能脱身。我脱不了身，但你能。我不能做精神错乱辩护，但你可以。你脑子出问题了。出去强奸某人是一回事，
but to kill somebody in cold blood and not have any compassion at all. That worried me. It's been worrying me for weeks since it happened. Because you told me it wouldn't bother you, but I thought it would. Watts responded coldly. I'd like to do it again. You wanted to as well. You wanted to do it again. The couple began planning a suicide pact scheduled to be carried out the following week on the one year anniversary of their marriage. On December 15, 1987, the day before what would have been chance 13th birthday, Barry Watts and Valme Beck were formally charged with her abduction, rape, and murder.
但冷血地杀害一个人却毫无同情心。这让我担忧。自从事情发生以来，它已经困扰我好几个星期了。因为你告诉我这不会困扰你，但我认为它会。沃茨冷酷地回答。我还想再来一次。你也想。你也想再来一次。这对夫妇开始策划一场自杀契约，预定在第二周他们的结婚一周年纪念日实施。1987年12月15日，也就是肖本该迎来13岁生日的前一天，巴里·沃茨和瓦尔梅·贝克被正式指控犯有绑架、强奸和谋杀罪。
The two were sent to separate prisons to await their trials, where they were put among the general population. Barry Watts did not have an easy time in prison. Due to the fact his crimes involved a child, he was targeted by other inmates. As the date of his wedding anniversary approached, a correctional officer at the Brisbane prison complex found Watts crying in his cell, claiming that he was sick of being hassled for Sean Kingey's murder. When the officer pointed out he had to expect some harassment for that sort of crime, Watts denied killing Sean, admitting only to having sexually assaulted her. When the officer then asked who had killed Sean, Barry Watts replied, she did. Valme Beck.
两人被送往不同的监狱等待审判，在那里他们与普通犯人关押在一起。巴里·沃茨在狱中过得并不轻松。由于他的罪行涉及儿童，他成为了其他囚犯针对的目标。随着结婚纪念日的临近，布里斯班监狱综合大楼的一名管教员发现沃茨在牢房里哭泣，声称他厌倦了因肖·金吉的谋杀案而受到骚扰。当狱警指出这种罪行本就该预料到会有一些骚扰时，沃茨否认杀害了肖，只承认曾对她进行性侵犯。当狱警接着问是谁杀了肖时，巴里·沃茨回答说，是她干的。瓦尔梅·贝克。
The killer couple's December wedding anniversary came and went, and neither Barry Watts nor Valme Beck upheld their side of their suicide pact. The pair didn't see each other again until April the following year, when they arrived at the Noosa Heads Magistrates Court for their committal hearing. There, they were greeted by a noose hanging from the court clock tower, and hundreds of people with placards who had gathered to scream abuse at them. When the detectives who had led the tireless investigation arrived to the courthouse, the mood of the crowd suddenly changed. Someone called out for three cheers, as enthusiastic applause erupted. It was a moment of great pride for the officers, many of whom were used to the
这对杀人夫妇的十二月结婚纪念日转瞬即逝，巴里·沃茨和瓦尔梅·贝克都没有履行他们的自杀契约。直到第二年四月，当他们来到努沙黑德地方法院参加初审听证会时，两人才再次相见。在那里，迎接他们的是挂在法院钟楼上的一条绞索，以及数百名举着标语聚集在一起对他们破口大骂的人。当领导了这场坚持不懈的调查的侦探们抵达法院时，人群的情绪突然发生了变化。有人高呼三呼万岁，热烈的掌声骤然爆发。这对警官们来说是一个极具骄傲的时刻，他们中的许多人已经习惯了
public's contempt and disapproval in an era marred by police corruption. When the committal hearings commenced, Valme Beck pleaded guilty to Sean Kingey's abduction and rape, but not guilty to her murder. Her husband Barry Watts pleaded not guilty on all charges. As the pair had turned on one another and were now accusing the other for Sean Kingey's murder, they were committed to stand trial separately. Valme Beck's trial came first, beginning in October 1988. Beck's written confession took 90 minutes for the prosecution to read out in full, detailing every lurid detail. Later, Beck told the shocked and sickened court that Sean, quote, never cried, never shed a tear. A brave little girl. She never uttered a peep. She just did everything,
在那个充满警察腐败的时代，公众的蔑视与不赞同。初审听证会开始时，瓦尔梅·贝克对肖·金吉的绑架和强奸罪名表示认罪，但对谋杀罪名表示不认罪。她的丈夫巴里·沃茨对所有指控均表示不认罪。由于两人已经反目成仇，现在正互相指控对方谋杀肖·金吉，因此他们被移交分开受审。瓦尔梅·贝克的审判率先进行，始于1988年10月。控方花了90分钟才将贝克的书面供词完整宣读完毕，其中详细描述了每一个骇人听闻的细节。随后，贝克向震惊且作呕的法庭表示，肖，原句是，从不哭泣，从未流过一滴眼泪。一个勇敢的小女孩。她没有吭一声。她只是做了一切，
he told her. Beck painted herself as a passive observer and unwilling participant to the crime, motivated by a man she loved and was afraid to lose. She told the court, I didn't feel I had the qualities to hold a man, and I was terrified Barry was going to leave me for a younger woman. However, the prosecution then presented the court with the audio collected from the covert listening devices placed in the accused's cells shortly after their arrest. During one recording, Beck told her husband that she had left out of her confession, quote, what happened between her and me? This indicated Beck was a far more active participant in the attack on Sean Kingey than she was willing to admit.
他告诉她的事。贝克将自己描绘成这起罪行的旁观者和不情愿的参与者，其动机是一个她爱且害怕失去的男人。她对法庭说，我觉得自己不具备留住一个男人的素质，我吓坏了，害怕巴里会为了一个更年轻的女人而离开我。然而，控方随后向法庭出示了从这对被告被捕后不久放置在他们牢房里的隐蔽监听设备中收集到的音频。在其中一段录音中，贝克告诉她的丈夫，她没有把以下内容写进供词中，原句是，我和她之间发生了什么。这表明贝克在袭击肖·金吉的过程中是一个比她愿意承认的更为积极的参与者。
Barry Watts never made his own official statement to police, so there was nothing to contradict Valme Beck's version of events. At the conclusion of her trial, the jury took just three hours to find her guilty of Sean Kingey's murder, believing she was an active and willing participant. On October 20, 1988, Queensland Supreme Court Justice Kelly called Valme Beck callous and depraved, before sentencing her to three years imprisonment for the abduction, 10 years for the rape, and life for the murder of Sean Kingey. Valme Beck quickly became the most hated woman in Australia and was targeted by other inmates, many of whom had children of their own and couldn't understand how a mother of six could do
巴里·沃茨从未向警方做过正式供述，因此没有任何言论与瓦尔米·贝克的事件版本相矛盾。在庭审结束时，陪审团仅用了三个小时就裁定她谋杀肖恩·金吉罪名成立，认为她是积极且自愿的参与者。1988年10月20日，昆士兰州最高法院法官凯利斥责瓦尔米·贝克冷酷无情、堕落至极，随后判处她因绑架罪入狱3年，因强奸罪入狱10年，因谋杀肖恩·金吉罪被判终身监禁。瓦尔米·贝克很快成了澳大利亚最受恨之入骨的女性，并成为其他犯人的袭击目标。这些犯人中许多人自己也有孩子，无法理解一个拥有六个孩子的母亲怎么能做出
something so depraved to an innocent child for the sake of a man. Urine and feces were thrown at Beck regularly and spread out around her prison cell, and she was subject to frequent violent attacks, sometimes to the point of unconsciousness. After being seriously injured by a blow to the head from a tin can in a sock, Beck was transferred to another correctional centre in Townsville for her own safety. Barry Watts stood trial for the abduction, rape and murder of Sean Kingey a year after his wife, still maintaining his innocence on all charges. As Watts had made no admissions, the prosecution relied heavily on the covert recordings of his conversations with Valme Beck following their arrest. The recordings were
为了一个男人对无辜儿童做出如此令人发指的事。尿液和粪便经常被泼在贝克身上，并涂抹在她的牢房四周，她还经常遭受暴力袭击，有时甚至被打得失去知觉。在被一只装着罐头的袜子重击头部导致严重受伤后，为了自身安全，贝克被转移到汤斯维尔的另一个惩教中心。在妻子被判刑一年后，巴里·沃茨因绑架、强奸和谋杀肖恩·金吉出庭受审，并且对所有指控坚决否认。由于沃茨没有做过任何供认，控方严重依赖他被捕后与瓦尔米·贝克对话的秘密录音。这些录音
corroborated by Beck herself, who had since divorced her husband and agreed to testify against him. Elizabeth Young, the woman who had witnessed Barry Watts behaving suspiciously on Castaway's beach shortly before he abducted and murdered Sean Kingey, testified at his trial. She said she wanted to look Watts straight in the eye and have him, quote, go to bed every single night thinking there is a woman out there who put him behind bars. Although Elizabeth provided investigators with the breakthrough needed to identify Sean's killers, she struggled with the guilt of not reporting Watts before he had the opportunity to harm Sean. Quote, my big regret is that I didn't do something on the first day, but it's like
得到了贝克本人的证实。她当时已经与丈夫离婚，并同意出庭指控他。伊丽莎白·扬是那个在巴里·沃茨绑架并谋杀肖恩·金吉前不久，目击他在卡斯特韦海滩行为可疑的女性，她在审判中出庭作证。她说她想直视沃茨的眼睛，让他“每天晚上睡觉时都想着，外面有一个女人把他送进了监狱”。尽管伊丽莎白为调查人员提供了锁定肖恩凶手所需的关键突破，但她一直饱受内疚折磨，自责为什么没有在沃茨有机会伤害肖恩之前报警。“我最大的遗憾就是第一天没有采取行动，但这就像
trying to prevent a car accident before it happens. Nothing I did was ever going to bring her back, but I stopped him from doing it to anyone else. Barry Watts' trial lasted eight days. On February 8, 1990, after six hours of deliberations, a jury found him guilty of Sean Kingey's abduction, rape, and murder. He was sentenced to three years, 15 years, and a life, respectively. Upon sentencing, Queensland Supreme Court Justice Kelly remarked, quote, the vulgar crime shows you to be an evil man void of any sense of morality. Justice Kelly told the court the circumstances of Sean Kingey's murder were so abhorrent that Barry Watts' file should be marked, never to be released. While he was in prison, Barry Watts
试图在车祸发生前阻止它一样。我做的一切都无法让她复活，但我阻止了他对其他人下手。”巴里·沃茨的审判持续了八天。1990年2月8日，经过六小时的审议，陪审团裁定他绑架、强奸和谋杀肖恩·金吉罪名成立。他分别被判处3年、15年监禁以及终身监禁。宣判时，昆士兰州最高法院法官凯利评论道：“这起下流的罪行表明你是一个毫无道德感的恶魔。”凯利法官对法庭表示，肖恩·金吉谋杀案的情节极其令人发指，巴里·沃茨的档案应当标注“永不得假释”。在服刑期间，巴里·沃茨
boasted to other inmates about the murder of not only Sean Kingey, but of another young woman as well. To determine the validity of these claims, an undercover police officer was planted in Barry Watts' cell in an attempt to coax information from the convicted killer. Meanwhile, investigators combed through missing person and unsolved murder cases, hoping to find a connection to Barry Watts. One case that stood out to investigators was the disappearance of 31-year-old Queensland mother, Helen Mary Feeney. Helen was a petite woman with light, sandy hair, who had vanished at 6.30pm on October 29, 1987, mere weeks before Sean Kingey's murder. Helen Feeney was studying to be a teacher at a college in North Brisbane. Her white, holding Gemini sedan was found abandoned
向其他犯人吹嘘自己不仅谋杀了肖恩·金吉，还谋杀了另一名年轻女性。为了确定这些说法的真实性，一名卧底警察被安插进巴里·沃茨的牢房，企图诱使这名已被定罪的杀人犯吐露信息。与此同时，调查人员仔细梳理失踪人口和未破谋杀案，希望找到与巴里·沃茨的关联。其中一个引起调查人员注意的案件是31岁昆士兰母亲海伦·玛丽·菲尼的失踪案。海伦身材娇小，有着浅沙色的头发，于1987年10月29日傍晚6点30分失踪，就在肖恩·金吉遇害前几周。海伦·菲尼当时正在布里斯班北部的一所学院学习教师专业。她白色的霍顿双子座轿车被发现遗弃在
in the college's parking lot. The driver's side windows smashed. No sign of Helen had since been found, and she was presumed murdered. The timing of Helen's disappearance coincided with the beginning of Barry Watts and Valmay Beck's crime spree. Less than two weeks after Helen vanished, Watts and Beck attempted to abduct three women in Ipswich, located just 40km away from Helen's college. Investigators pressed Watts for information about Helen Feeney, saying they wanted to pronounce her dead and locate her remains to provide closure for her family. But the convicted killer denied having anything to do with the mother's disappearance. Once again, Valmay Beck implicated her ex-husband, telling investigators that
学院的停车场里。驾驶座一侧的车窗被砸碎。此后一直没有找到海伦的踪迹，她被推定已经遇害。海伦失踪的时间巧合地与巴里·沃茨和瓦尔迈·贝克的犯罪狂潮开始时间重合。在海伦失踪不到两周后，沃茨和贝克试图在伊普斯威奇绑架三名女性，该地距离海伦的学院仅40公里。调查人员向沃茨施压，要求提供关于海伦·菲尼的信息，称他们希望宣布她死亡并找到她的遗骸，以便给她的家人一个交代。但这位已被定罪的杀人犯否认自己与这位母亲的失踪有任何关系。瓦尔迈·贝克再次牵连了她的前夫，告诉调查人员
Watts killed the young mother during a bungled car break in. According to Beck, they parked a couple of spaces away from a small, white car, and she acted as a lookout for Watts as he broke into the vehicle. Beck heard the sound of glass smashing, and shortly thereafter, Watts placed something wrapped in a red dune into the rear of their station wagon. Beck claimed she did not see a body, but, quote, vaguely saw what looked like somebody's sandy coloured hair. Beck claimed Watts told her that Helen had disturbed him breaking into the car, and she was now dead. Beck said Watts dumped the red dune and its contents at the Lowood rubbish tip and watched it burn.
沃茨是在一次搞砸的砸车盗窃中杀害了这位年轻母亲的。据贝克称，他们将车停在距离一辆白色小车几个车位的地方，当沃茨破窗入室时，她在旁边把风。贝克听到玻璃破碎的声音，不久之后，沃茨将一个用红色沙丘毯包裹的东西放进了旅行车的后备箱。贝克声称她没有看到尸体，但“隐约看到像是某人沙色头发的东西”。贝克声称沃茨告诉她，海伦打扰了他砸车行窃，现在已经死了。贝克说沃茨把红色的沙丘毯及里面的东西扔到了洛伍德垃圾填埋场并看着它们燃烧。
Based on further information provided by Beck, police believed Helen's remains may have been relocated and buried at a different location, somewhere between Lowood and Wyvernhoe Dam. The subsequent searches of these areas resulted in no discoveries. Barry Watts was put on trial for Helen Feeney's murder in 1995, but no evidence could be found to corroborate Velmae Beck's assertions that her former husband was responsible for the crime. Barry Watts continued to deny any involvement in Helen's disappearance, and the inmates Watts allegedly confessed to were uncooperative in court. Information gathered by the undercover police officer who shared a cell with Watts was not permitted into evidence.
根据贝克提供的进一步信息，警方认为海伦的遗骸可能被转移并埋葬在另一个地方，位于洛伍德和怀芬霍水坝之间的某个地方。随后的搜查没有取得任何发现。巴里·沃茨于1995年因海伦·菲尼谋杀案受审，但找不到任何证据来证实维尔梅·贝克关于其前夫应对该罪行负责的断言。巴里·沃茨继续否认参与海伦的失踪，而沃茨据称向其坦白的犯人在法庭上不予配合。与沃茨同监室的卧底警察收集的信息未被允许作为证据采纳。
That officer suffered a nervous breakdown and resigned from the police force, attributing his collapse partly to the horror of working on the case. The lack of compelling evidence saw a body, coupled with unreliable testimony from Velmae Beck, resulted in Barry Watts being acquitted of Helen Mae Feeney's murder. Her case remains unsolved to this day. In 1993, Velmae Beck fell in love with notorious serial rapist Robert John Fadden, after meeting him at an annual prison barbecue put on for lifers. Their relationship lasted several years, and by 1998, Fadden wanted to become Beck's fourth husband, going so far as asking a pastor if he could purchase an engagement ring through mail order.
那名警官随后精神崩溃并辞去了警职，并将他的崩溃部分归咎于参与此案的恐怖经历。缺乏确凿证据以及尸体的缺失，加上维尔梅·贝克不可靠的证词，导致巴里·沃茨被判海伦·梅·菲尼谋杀罪名不成立。她的案件至今仍未破获。1993年，维尔梅·贝克在终身犯年度监狱烧烤上遇到臭名昭著的连环强奸犯罗伯特·约翰·法登后，与之坠入爱河。他们的关系持续了好几年，到1998年，法登想成为贝克的第四任丈夫，甚至向牧师询问是否可以通过邮购购买一枚订婚戒指。
The couple were denied the opportunity to marry, and Fadden was relocated to a different prison. Their relationship appeared to have stopped there. Velmae Beck later converted to Christianity, and cold case detectives periodically interviewed her about Helen Feeney and other unsolved cases, in the hopes that the convicted killers knew found religious beliefs would compel her to confess to other crimes. However, Beck offered no information. In 2003, Beck was in the newspapers again, this time for befriending controversial politician Pauline Hansen, who was serving time for electoral fraud. After her release, Pauline Hansen told Woman's Day magazine that she felt sorry for Beck, and the two had become close in
这对情侣被拒绝结婚，法登被转移到了另一座监狱。他们的关系似乎到此为止。维尔梅·贝克后来改信了基督教，冷案侦探们定期就海伦·菲尼和其他未破案件采访她，希望这位已被定罪的杀人犯新发现的宗教信仰能迫使她坦白其他罪行。然而，贝克没有提供任何信息。2003年，贝克再次登上报纸，这次是因为与因选举欺诈而服刑的争议政治人物波林·汉森结为朋友。刑满释放后，波林·汉森告诉《女性日》杂志，她对贝克感到同情，两人在
prison after they, quote, had a laugh and hit it off. Hansen described Beck as a very nice lady who she was glad to have met, adding that the convicted child rapist and killer had provided assistance, help, and friendship when Hansen needed it. The politician's remarks fueled public backlash and elicited a response from Sean Kingey's family, who had up until that point avoided speaking publicly about their daughter's murder. A spokesperson for the Kingey family called Pauline Hansen naive and condemned the politician's lack of clear judgment. After serving almost 20 years of her life sentence, Velmae Beck tried several times to get parole, but her request was denied each time. In May 2007, she told Townsville Correctional Center staff she had significant
监狱里“聊得很开心并且一拍即合”。汉森将贝克描述为一个她很高兴认识的非常好的女士，并补充说，这位因虐童被定罪的强奸犯和杀人犯在汉森需要时提供了援助、帮助和友谊。这位政治人物的言论引发了公众的反弹，并招致了肖恩·金吉家人的回应，他们在此之前一直避免公开谈论女儿的谋杀案。金吉一家的发言人称波林·汉森天真，并谴责这位政治人物缺乏清晰的判断力。在服完近20年的无期徒刑后，维尔梅·贝克曾数次试图申请假释，但每次请求都被拒绝。2007年5月，她告诉汤斯维尔惩教中心的工作人员，她有关于
information in relation to the disappearance of Helen Feeney, but subsequent questioning proved fruitless and led to no breakthroughs in the case. By 2008, Velmae Beck had a number of severe health problems. After being hospitalized for minor heart surgery in May that year, Beck's condition deteriorated and she was put into an induced coma. Detectives remained convinced that Beck knew more about other crimes than she ever admitted and held out hopes for a deathbed confession. There was heated debate about whether Beck, who had expressed the desire not to be resuscitated, should be kept alive for that reason. On May 27, 2008, 64-year-old Velmae Beck died in custody at Townsville Hospital from complications arising from heart surgery. Investigators never got their
海伦·菲尼失踪的重要信息，但随后的讯问证明毫无结果，也没有给案件带来任何突破。到2008年，维尔梅·贝克出现了许多严重的健康问题。当年5月因轻微心脏手术住院后，贝克的病情恶化，并被置于人工诱导昏迷状态。侦探们仍然确信贝克对其他罪行的了解比她承认的要多，并对临终忏悔抱有希望。关于是否应为此让表达过不希望被抢救意愿的贝克继续活着，曾引发了激烈的争论。2008年5月27日，64岁的维尔梅·贝克在汤斯维尔医院因心脏手术引发的并发症在羁押中死亡。调查人员最终没有得到
deathbed confession. Any secrets Beck may have had died with her. Nusa Detective Sergeant Bob Atkinson, who had previously led the investigation into Shang Kingi's disappearance and murder, was later promoted to police commissioner. Atkinson said he was positive Shang Kingi was not the only victim of Barry Watts and the late Velmae Beck, telling reporters, quote, given the fact that Watts and Beck were so active, so ruthless, so organized, I find it difficult to believe that the only things they did were the ones we know about. Atkinson never forgot the case of Shang Kingi. Memories of the 1987 case flattered back in 2003, when the Sunshine Coast was shaken by the unexplained disappearance of
临终忏悔。贝克可能掌握的任何秘密都随着她的死而长眠。曾领导肖恩·金吉失踪和谋杀案调查的努萨侦探警长鲍勃·阿特金森后来晋升为警察局长。阿特金森表示，他确信肖恩·金吉并不是巴里·沃茨和已故的维尔迈·贝克的唯一受害者，他告诉记者：“鉴于沃茨和贝克如此活跃、如此冷酷、如此有组织，我很难相信他们仅做了我们所知道的那些事。”阿特金森从未忘记肖恩·金吉的案件。1987年案件的记忆在2003年再次浮现，当时阳光海岸因另一起离奇失踪案而震惊，受害者是
13-year-old Daniel Morgham. Just like he had done for the Kingi family, Atkinson promised the Morghams he would never let the police service give up on finding their child. The disappearance of Daniel Morgham is covered in Case 54 of case file. In 2009, 53-year-old Barry Watts sought parole, but he could only be considered if he took responsibility and expressed remorse for his crimes. This led to Watts finally breaking his 20-year silence about the murder of Shang Kingi. In an interview described by detectives as chilling, Watts made a full confession. His parole application was denied. Barry Watts remains in prison today. He has shown zero remorse for the murder of Shang Kingi
13岁的丹尼尔·莫勒姆。就像他当年对金吉一家所做的那样，阿特金森向莫勒姆一家保证，他绝不会让警察部门放弃寻找他们的孩子。丹尼尔·莫勒姆的失踪案收录在案件档案的第54案中。2009年，53岁的巴里·沃茨寻求假释，但他只有在承担责任并对自己的罪行表现出悔意的情况下才会被考虑。这导致沃茨最终打破了他关于谋杀肖恩·金吉的20年沉默。在一次被侦探们描述为令人毛骨悚然的采访中，沃茨作出了全面交待。他的假释申请被拒绝。巴里·沃茨今天仍在监狱中服刑。他为谋杀肖恩·金吉表现出零悔意
and has never confessed to any other crimes. Those involved with the case have vowed to do everything in their power to ensure that Watts will never be released. Former Sunshine Coast detective Alan Burke worked on many horrendous crimes over the years, but nothing made quite the same emotional impact as the Shang Kingi case. Quote, Anyone that was directly involved in that homicide was never the same again. It was horrific. Through that initial period, we found out Shang had a loving family. She was a lovely girl with a future in front of her. We were hoping she'd turn up,
并且从未承认任何其他罪行。那些参与此案的人发誓要尽一切力量确保沃茨永远不会被释放。前阳光海岸侦探艾伦·伯克多年来处理过许多可怕的罪行，但没有任何案件像肖恩·金吉案那样产生如此巨大的情感冲击。“任何直接参与那起凶杀案的人都再也回不到从前了。太可怕了。在那段最初的时期里，我们发现肖恩有一个充满爱的家庭。她是一个可爱的女孩，前途无量。我们曾希望她能出现，
and to see her murdered was absolutely shattering. Shang was a passionate netball player and loved hitting the courts with her team on the weekends. Her tall, slim frame towered over many of her smaller peers, making her quite the intimidating competitor. During the heat of a contest, Shang would sometimes accidentally knock other opponents over. When this happened, she would immediately stop playing mid-game to pick them up, give them a friendly brush down, and ask kindly, are you alright? The Kingi family have never spoken publicly about Shang's murder. Their focus has always remained on celebrating Shang's life, remembering her as their smiling, free-spirited daughter who
看到她被谋杀绝对是令人心碎的。”肖恩是一名热情的无网篮球运动员，喜欢在周末和她的球队一起上场。她高挑纤细的身材在许多较小的同龄人中显得高人一等，这使她成为了一个相当具有威慑力的竞争对手。在激烈的比赛中，肖恩有时会不小心撞倒其他对手。当这种情况发生时，她会立刻在比赛中途停下来把他们拉起来，友好地拍拍他们身上的灰尘，并亲切地问：“你还好吗？”金吉一家从未公开谈论过肖恩的谋杀案。他们的焦点始终放在庆祝肖恩的生命上，把她铭记为他们那个爱笑、自由奔放的女儿，她
loved parties, riding her bike, netball, jazz ballet, and who would always stop whatever she was doing to pick others up when they needed it. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
喜欢派对、骑自行车、无网篮球、爵士芭蕾，而且无论在做什么，只要别人需要，她总是会停下来把别人拉起来。该集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。